two good Monday top of the Monday to
y'all it's December 5th huh it is almost
the end of the year my friends in fact
we only have 15 days left before our
winter break that's right and before our
live show that's right final show of the
year so happy uh holidays and merry
winter
we're here God damn it it's H3 podcast
sponsored by Gamers sup we love gamer
sub let me hit with this real fast
and thank you Philly D for your support
on the gamer sub ads always appreciate
that
yeah how's everybody doing uh you know
it's Monday I was I look forward to
Monday so I gotta be honest thank you
Lena
you know
anyone here from Arizona
but so we had a little bit of a
bamboozle plan today actually a pretty
fun show for for a change
um finally
yeah so the streamies happened you know
I was super hyped about it this year
I tried to play the game that was my
theory because this is like our fifth
time being nominated for streamy
and um
I tried to play the game little did they
know that they were the ones being
played that's right roll the steamy
soundtrack because that's the only show
that matters I watched the streamies
that show [ __ ] sucks like we all knew
it did everyone there's a hack
all right calm down Ethan
Hassan won an award I'm happy for him no
but actually we sent an impersonator
because I wasn't going to that [ __ ] come
on you know what I mean I said I my
whole theory was if I want to win I got
to play the game and try to act like I
care so I Arvis are I still don't win by
the way irishvp'd yes
I said we're coming
we're coming and waves
[Music]
and um I sent a look-alike we actually
had an Ela look alike but she canceled
last minute which is a shame because she
actually looked like you look the guy
who played me didn't look anything like
me but I almost made it more funny just
generic white guy
and uh since the Girl canceled actually
Ian got we only had two tickets so Ian
got to go with him which was actually a
blessing in the end because Ian was able
to record the whole thing
and uh how was it how was you did you
have a good time there Ian with uh Ethan
Bizarro Ethan
um yeah it was nice to bond with my boss
yeah spend some time together it's been
a long time coming so that was important
to me for sure some quality time yeah
um well we were kind of just working it
was funny we were the only people with a
camera who was able to nobody else was
no everyone's like we don't give a [ __ ]
about this yeah for a room of like
streamers and YouTubers we're the only
dummies with this giant camera walking
around the whole time that is
interesting no one else wanted to film
anything there it's like
okay maybe they're embarrassed yeah I
would be embarrassed but hey I wasn't
there yeah
yo I was thinking we got to start
sending
Bizarro Ethan on [ __ ] like send him on a
hike with Philly D yeah
send Bizarro Ethan
um
Street comedy with Jimmy Lee Gabe's
birthday party I'm gonna start making
I'm gonna start making some good use
laughs
of Bizarro Ethan
yeah
um the show was was horrible though and
I'm not trying to be a hater I mean we
all watched it
right it's just some bear you know what
I mean it's like come on guys it's socks
true
yeah so we have a full segment uh coming
up on that a little bit but let's get to
some top of the show shenanigans
welcome everybody happy Monday
actually our Teddy fresh winter
collection is out and we made the
long-awaited sequel
to the H3 podcast
presents Teddy fresh so here is
long-awaited a lot one month awaited a
long-awaited
if even it's a week submitted maybe only
two weeks since the last one maybe it
was longer
let's say three yeah so anyway here is
um H3 podcast presents Teddy fresh
December 2022. Teddy fresh when hold on
let me let me
let me put this all nice for you guys
okay Teddy fresh winter 2022 how you
doing it's that hoodie box logo with
extra moves on top okay put that thing
away ela's looking good with the fuzzy
collar neon damn and the and the makeup
whoa 100 on point as always Dan he's
doing his best ladies and gentlemen give
it up for Dan the sweater looks great
though so thanks for trying Sam okay
quilted
um and vibrant just like her heart and
soul Lina crushing it but the uh teddy
bear jacket I love this jacket it's so
nice it's so beautiful yeah we she's got
eyes on us uh Ian okay we love it a b
with the bare ears this is a Vibe he's
pulling it off love to see it
cam okay Power stance zip it up cross it
out Zach is wow Fabio where's he gotta
get it Olivia took her slave pill this
morning okay Queen it's teddyfresh.com
yeah a little weird or love but you know
I don't mean to say where you did a
great job editing that baby I didn't
mean anything by that
it was a tough one for five minutes I
had right now I I'm proud of it
just kind of cuts off hard but that's
not your fault I just want to make that
clear I said to just leave it off like
that yeah make that clear
it's not your fault yes so there it is
that and so much more at teddyfresh.com
and everyone is saying Dan has never
looked good so everybody's arguing it's
true I knew that was I had to keep it
going and uh
Dan's just never quite good enough for
me
it's not your fault
anyway there's actually so much nice
stuff
head on over to teddyfresh.com and
actually it's perfect time to get your
friend your loved ones a gift this is a
Gary Kennedy one look at this [ __ ] I
Gotta Wear this
my ride or die emotional support
my best friend Angel on Earth my soul
mate
love it
Christmas is one day and for the kitty
people
Christmas is one day why do the gays get
a whole month
why is this up is it from pre-show okay
yeah
anyway there it is it is thank you and
thank you everybody so that's nice good
times see this uh donation from Nicole
no what happened six month member twenty
dollars I met Ian at the Streamys last
night and I got so excited the stunt
double was hilarious too oh wait why
were you there Nicole do you remember
meeting Nicole or did a lot of people
say hi in
I think I remember Nicole yeah
um people are very nice
I I forget people watch our show it's
great and so yeah I know me too and so
were people like is Nicole a Creator or
something or oh someone did come up to
me and he went I think he was a little
intoxicated open bar I understand but he
came up and he was like
yo
H3 I love you Dan oh no
wait to you or to the person to me uh I
was like close enough how much can he
really love you yeah
I'm fine so what were people weirded out
they came up and said hi to you guys
sorry I won't slip into the mic y'all
Jesus
some of y'all are so sensitive we're
people Nicole is a YouTuber oh hi Nicole
we love you
yeah were people weirded out they came
and said hi
no no I mean everyone everyone was
really nice
um but like by that there's just a fake
impersonator Ethan oh they I they
everyone thought that was great okay I
also noticed a lot of people
um were taking like sneak photos of his
Streamys hell yeah on the back of his
jacket yeah so obviously we didn't go
there just to enjoy the event we went
there within ulterior motive can you
link me to Nicole's um page because I
want to represent the fuper Troopers out
there there you go love just sent it
this this is um
the super famous thanks it's pretty big
uh
girl who came and said hi to you uh Ian
Nicole concilio
concilio
yes Nicole he was very nice and now I
remember you remember her yeah I don't
know if you remembered her enough she's
a big fan in
Nicole comes up to you
big fan of the show
and you don't even remember her face
she talked to the impersonator Ian that
wasn't me
oh you had a double too yeah yeah that's
what that's what happened I remember
there's like three layers deep yeah yeah
um impersonators can we show I want to
show the streamies uh
the photo here since I know we're gonna
get to the segment in a minute but
since we're already on it here is
by the way you guys oh yeah the Getty
Images now has images of the look-alike
with my name
we got him the like goofiest
[ __ ] suit this [ __ ] doesn't fit
him at all I was gonna spend a lot of
money on this [ __ ] you know what I mean
we paid him like 500 bucks that was a
good that was my budget
I dialed that wig
I love it yeah that wig is not
what was his natural hair like
I never saw it oh he showed up in the
lake method actor so here it is Ethan
Klein attends the 2022 YouTube streaming
Awards of Beverly Hilton
congratulations looking good Ethan
my favorite is The Vape niche and then
look at this streamies [ __ ] y'all
know what it is
go for 500 a pop yeah
if you want them
we we went obviously to promote our show
which is the only true and good
Hollywood uh or YouTube award show
babe Nash so you know it's me
it's like the worst favorite
it's only one finger he just learned how
to do that
he did a lot of research yeah he's a
method actor really
Ethan Klein attends to 2022 YouTube
award show so there he is the red carpet
you guys got the red carpet treatment
huh
oh yeah he was soaking it in soaking in
Ethan Klein
he looks a little blazed I was gonna say
he looks blown as [ __ ]
they'll get in that's my boy it's me
Ethan Clyde
at the 2020 to I don't know who this is
it's me Daddy
Ian Slater that's when Nicole met
yeah so good it was so good uh so fun so
there that is
all right let's talk about some top of
the show Shenanigans first
thank you
so okay first of all we had a great show
on Friday with Bradley Martin of Nell
yeah that was great it was a great show
everybody loved it Brant Bradley turns
out is a great dude we're besties now we
were chatting on we've been texting and
stuff Donnie
mm-hmm
yeah the poll by the way closed not it
was like uh like 50 000 votes said 90
yes they believe
that uh Steve jerked off that's [ __ ]
up yeah I know he I believe him he said
it didn't happen and why I shouldn't why
do I should I believe him yeah but the
spicy chip I wanted to say
that
I felt like a b after the show I puked
I was hunched over
I had I don't think I've ever
experienced pain like that my whole life
my stomach was cramping
and it was so so bad
yeah he's not lying he disappeared into
the bathroom after the show for about 45
minutes I would say and we were hearing
him violently puke in there for a while
oh yeah super loud you guys probably
heard yeah oh yeah we did I turned my
headphones
I puked super loud I don't know why just
like
I can't help Ireland yeah I was
downstairs I heard it I ran up when I
heard he's throwing up like that yeah we
were upstairs we were trying to figure
out if you were doing it on purpose like
trying to make yourself coming out like
on its own no that's real [ __ ] right
there dude bored yourself until you're
on the verge I was thinking as I was
puking too like this is so loud but I
wish I could lower the decibels but I I
just can't
uh Taylor says my longtime fupa Troopa
got married on Friday she's watching the
show surprise Gabby and Angelo happy
wedding
love you thanks Gabby and Angelo
yeah yeah people are clamoring people
are clamoring for a winter background
cam
I'll get a gun for an extra well I mean
I saw this request too it is it's not
winter yet not winter yeah officially
you're in the fall still yeah it's
December though come on it's Christmas I
guess it's true yeah because winter
doesn't even start till January or some
[ __ ] right or no it's December 21st 21st
yeah so
cutting it pretty close to Christmas
I'll get it done don't worry guys
we got you Cam we know you will
uh so I was I was thinking of you the
whole time though ab and uh just you
know
I was just thinking how I should have
believed you you know what I mean I yeah
I I didn't know you didn't believe me
yeah yeah I didn't
well the truth is I realized I didn't I
had an empty stomach you're right and
you said you had an empty stomach when
you did it too right yeah because the
last time I slammed a massive burrito
and Pepto-Bismol I didn't do either of
those things and I just was in so much
pain so
yeah I I felt like a [ __ ] last time I
didn't eat anything but I didn't expect
to be that bad because I only lasted
like 10 seconds before I had to to drink
and yeah
it was rough
I think if you eat food you're fine I
would do it again but I would definitely
need to eat food again
at the time I was like I'm never doing
that again and you need the Pepto-Bismol
Chaser too I think that helps yeah you
know what I mean
but when I puked I was
it was all just tasted like Pepto-Bismol
um because after the fact I started
slamming Pepto
and I just had pink sweet
vile
uh it was it was not good these never
get easy yeah but the one thing I gotta
say
I brought Bradley on to kind of create a
piece
with the manosphere
me and Bradley bonded we had a good
bonding time
can you bring my speaker up a little bit
I can't hear the music okay thank you
this exercising thing is it I feel like
we really made some
Headway and we really
um you know came to an understanding
with each other now Bradley Martin has a
clip Channel
he says that it's a fan Channel I
actually I don't believe it's a fan
actually uh looking further into it
because Bradley actually commented on
the video so I think it's possibly
someone on his team that runs it for him
okay I'll just be I I asked him I said
oh what's the deal with this video bro
like and he said that he knows the guy
who runs the channel I don't know I I
don't know if he's paying him I don't
know
I think he he acts on autonomously got
it got it okay he doesn't take
directions from Bradley
it's not your fault yes so he then he so
his his guy
so I I'm trying to make it clear this
isn't Bradley's fault
but it does seem to be official to some
degree because it has like his code and
his website and [ __ ] I don't think
anyone's doing this for
just doing this for Love of the Game I
don't know this exercising but this was
so [ __ ] up this actually made me feel
bad
so check this out this is what the alpha
Bros are doing to me
and this clip is going viral it's got
like a million views this exercising
thing is it it's just a giant scan
because if I just spent that time on the
treadmill doing something else maybe
maybe the time I spent on the treadmill
will end up being a less than the life I
save doing not not doing it yeah I see
what you're trying to say and the
numbers don't add up this is you [ __ ]
believe that is it just it's like a
Giants that's so [ __ ] up
hahaha and then if you go to the
comments
can you find the time stamp and show
like the original because I know a lot
of y'all probably watched it but I said
literally the exact opposite of that
and I just can't make any Headway with
these guys
Ethan Klein act like it's time so
valuable okay fine every time I say
Ethan I'm obligated to do 10 push-ups
fine good for you
um Ethan Klein it just don't add up yeah
that's not what I
Ethan motivates me to be the opposite of
what he is what broke [ __ ] lonely and
uh and uh
what's the opposite of me bro skinny
no you'll be broke Loveless [ __ ]
loser shut up
[Laughter]
telling that to the bodybuilder who owns
a gym yeah you maybe should try watching
the combo there's not one comment here
who's like I watch that this club's
[ __ ] up
okay when his legs start leaking fluid
at 50 maybe he'll feel different I don't
know what that means
legs start leaking fluid I'm not sure
about that referencing I'm not sure
yellow like that though
give a hour a day for two years and lose
over 100 pounds gain back years of your
life just don't add up that's what I
literally said in the clip
like [ __ ] literally what people say when
they just lay too lazy to work out Brad
looks so disappointed I don't even
understand what he's trying to say
like I'm done I'm done bro get out the
[ __ ] darts bro I'm done
I'm done exercising
bro my legs are already leaking fluid
[ __ ] this [ __ ] leaking legs a condition
known as
lymphora
causes fluid to leak from the legs what
it might from where like nothing's
diabetes you get leg holes from diabetes
leg holes yeah leg holes from diabetes
okay okay no I don't want that you're
right yeah I don't want that but am I
wrong in thinking just like how [ __ ]
up this is like a Bradley Martin fan
watch this and said I'm gonna I'm gonna
do the exact opposite of what he said
and just hate bait it's just it's
upsetting 2.65 years straight on the
treadmill so I said to myself
this exercising thing is it it's just a
giant scam because if I just spent that
time on the treadmill doing something
else maybe maybe the time I spent on the
treadmill will end up being a less than
the life I save doing not not doing do
you know yeah I see what you're trying
to say and boy I ended it by saying the
numbers don't add up okay so here's the
thing you should not take into account
then right you're not taking into
account the way you might yeah because
I'm dying at 64 right so let's say I get
down to a healthy weight yeah then what
then what are we feeling
I'll be in The Matrix in no time so that
could be 80 easily that's that's 16
years plus and so I'm spending 2.6 years
on the treadmill and I'm saving 16 plus
years so to me that's a good deal and I
crunch the numbers yeah and I said the
numbers don't add up it's a good deal
but it's a good deal I says I've just I
am upset by this uh because it's like so
[ __ ] up like these dudes are just such
pieces of [ __ ] I'm just spitting facts
you know I don't know am I being silly
this exercising thing is it I guess I
get why you're upset I mean I think this
is defamation I'll be straight up this
is actionable
stop it is no it's not you can't Dan
what are you a [ __ ] uh paralegal now
I know enough to know that it's not
actionable yeah to play Devil's Advocate
when I first saw this I thought maybe it
was because we made a joke about how
people are going to take what you were
saying now out of context and edit that
up yeah and what happened but yeah and
it's not acknowledged at all it's just
people hating me and it going viral
because I'm a I hate exercising now
Bradley replied to this with something
like
you got to let the whole clip play
right yeah but there you go their
comments get buried
and the Sea of hate like this guy wrote
it this is a joke and now it has 200
likes before it had 15 likes and it's
just these clips have like our comments
have like thousands and thousands like
you don't see Bradley commented like
it's out of context oh here it is it has
99 likes like nobody cares doing
something else maybe maybe the time I
spent on the treadmill will end up being
a less than the life I say wait what the
[ __ ] is this no Jesus all right I'm out
I guess I'm the only one I'm the only
one I mean it's about you so I
understand nobody [ __ ] cares hurts
your feelings more than yo can you put
on AstroWorld bro it is actionable
though it's a bad faith intentional
misrepresentation of what I said what
are the damage and it's hard the damages
is my good [ __ ] character bro
punitive damage I think you'd have to
prove that you had a good character
though let's go
well anything's possible uh with with
through God
laughs
people saying why are you butthurt dude
it's understanding it's [ __ ] they did me
so dirty nobody cares just me no am I
the only one that gives a [ __ ] about the
rules
what rules
what rules
all right crazy there you go I guess I'm
just never gonna take a dub you know I
brought your boy Bradley on no no you
brought him a good [ __ ] time yes we
brought our people into his world yes we
humanized him we show and he is a good
guy and we showed that we had a great
time and then like your response to that
by the way people who are like get in
the gym gym is life I'm in the gym
working out bettering myself and what
you're doing you're [ __ ] doing me
dirty just a hate click like it's just
not it's [ __ ] up yes it's like what
the [ __ ] I will say I remember we
screenshot it in our chat last night but
there were a couple comments from
Bradley fans that were like I don't
watch H3 but I watched this episode
because I because Bradley was on and
this was taken way out of context his
point was basically the opposite so you
did none of those some people but I'm
just saying you got through to some
people yeah you did I would none of
those comments got even like over 20
likes apparently well let's go juice it
hey Siri Nation go Jupiter it's like
that that clip is [ __ ] up I just I
don't know I don't think it's right I'm
thinking about suing them too yeah thank
you Kyle you're my boy I'm cool with
milk now
I'm trying to find because we screenshot
it I don't know get PNP on the phone
let's see if this is actionable let's go
someone says it's unfair and
uncharitable is it actionable though
because I want to [ __ ] Sue
I've never sued anyone in my life but
I'm coming after this Tick Tock account
yeah here right now bruh look I don't
side with h3h3 but I watch this podcast
because I like Bradley and this was
taken way out of context and the likes
on that that's 12 like 12 likes
12.
at the time at 12. no nobody read that
I told Bradley and he I was like Bradley
what's up dude this is your clip Channel
you're seriously gonna hit me like that
you're gonna do me like that and he said
I told the guy
the guy didn't take it down obviously he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
uh I said I I told Bradley I said leave
it up it's fine I I'm not I'm not
telling you guys what to do about it I
was just wondering if like you did this
or if it was like
because if he came on the show and then
uploaded that I'd be like bro that is
[ __ ] up but you know he didn't have
anything to do it though
do you actually want to ask PMP like
should we be trying to get a hold of him
right now or uh probably yeah that's
just a joke yeah just just making sure
it is actionable though I'll drive his
ass into the ground dude
[Music]
let's just say it is
somebody says you should assume for
being a big meanie yeah that's what I'm
being suited for it is actionable that's
what cavcv sued me for that's a good
point
John thank you for the 50 gift John
appreciate that on
uh there was a couple uh big donors too
during that I wanted to uh shout out oh
speaking of John by the way tomorrow is
our
members only live stream
see you next Tuesday we'll be live
tomorrow at 12 for members it's been so
much fun
I'm loving doing these so I look forward
to seeing all you guys there all your
members there thank you John who just
gifted 50 people
Chad is asking how ELO was doing after
the chip fine she's fine
she's totally fine I'm fine
dude you know I had that sound bite in
my head as I said it and you were right
on that always thinking baby always
thinking synergy synergy
um she was fine she was fine people just
wanted to shout out Gambler who donated
1300 uh pesos which I think is like 50
bucks or something
um he ate two chips after watching your
video and they made a bit a video about
it totally regret it but if you eat two
I'll eat three next time I didn't say
who said anything about eating too
I mean that was just a third of a chip
that [ __ ] you up on Friday that wasn't
even a whole chip so dude that chip was
cursed bro I don't know what the [ __ ]
man that thing
was cursed well you said you empty
stomach right empty stomach but the pain
in my mouth was more intense
I feel like the last time oh my God
another 50 gifted from John John John we
love John John is the king bro thank you
John King John
more like Saint John
anyway thank you thank you is John
you're the man my Jewish
okay
Ninja
I wasn't here for that uh
for that whole flaming ninja
conversation oh when he went full
anti-semite when he sieg heiled
yeah I'm out I'm out the ninja Wars have
just begun oh
it's so tragic we were so close that's
what I said I said dude I'm trying my
best to reform myself and and Ninja is
like my test like I can't change ninja
is testing me in ways God why do you
test me I was trying not to be a gator
ass [ __ ] I love that and then the wars
have just begun and then ninja come out
here talking about oh Jews have big
noses and they pick up change on the
floor although my nose is [ __ ] mad
wait I eat anything I only heard about
it
well if there's at least one then
there's gonna be the other one he's
starting to make like he's starting to I
saw Ninja on his stream yesterday being
like the numbers are greatly exaggerated
wow and I saying bro ninja the wars have
just begun and I'm sitting here trying
to turn a new Leaf [ __ ] time to burn
that leaf there's a lot of things that I
love about Hitler ninja by the way that
was Ninja saying that yeah yeah he
sounds different stop dissing the Nazis
all the time ninja so true friends to
the ninja and Kanye actually are on tour
together well you know
you know where Ninjas are from right
Japan axis
allies of Nazi Germany boom just saying
makes sense it's all connected
no such thing as a coincidence
I was gonna say Michigan because he's
from Michigan yeah yeah I was watching
Nick
I was watching ninja stream yesterday
and he was doing this whole bit about
Cookie Monster and you couldn't cook up
seriously [ __ ]
[ __ ] that anti-semite people are saying
is this actionable it is actionable
have you seen those him hit those
[ __ ] 360 no scopes in fortnite
yeah that's why he's gonna be posted on
the guard towers
I was trying to say that's I'm just
saying ultimately he's gonna be doing
360 no scopes on escaping prisoners
he's a [ __ ] monster I hate him dude
he's dead to me
[Music]
he's a monster dude
yeah
one of those DMS from his wife now oh
[ __ ] one of those Infamous DMS from his
wife yeah
I dare you bro your damn is actionable
as [ __ ]
me and Pokey are gonna do a clash act a
class action lawsuit against you guys
two people class action yeah but we
represent the class of people that ninja
has wronged we'll find more all two of
us I'll find that one kid he yelled at
he bullied on stream look at his
reaction right now look at this action
I'm sure there's some other people we
can find I'll start running like
infomercials at 5am has ninja wronged
you contact the law office of PNP
did Ninja call you naughty names on
fortnite
contact the law offices of PNP people
fight for you it's a scrub a noob
um no skill or any other
you could be entitled to a huge
compensation
call the law offices of PMP today
excuse me yeah he's dead to me in a
[ __ ] kid
yeah
so actually we've been enjoying
um there's been a whole slew of people
saying I'm gay
and it started with fousey then it went
to the FIFA World Cup president and then
we were reminded of this by from a song
of all people
of uh by this uh Andrew Cuomo moment he
also did the same thing so we're
actually building quite a
quite a bank here of people saying
they're gay
as in New York
New York is it New York
New Yorker I am black I am gay I am
disabled I am a woman seeking to control
her health and her choices because as a
New Yorker We Are One Community as a New
Yorker I am an elderly person whose
death is not being reported accurately
I am a Muslim I am an intern who's being
groped in the elevator
the the woman one really aged like milk
but him out about him people gotta stop
this this is not working for me as a
oratory uh speaking device it's just not
happening I do it with everyone I don't
know as a New Yorker I am Jewish
as a New Yorker I am blessed
black gay I am disabled I am gay I am
black I am I'm black I'm gay I'm
disabled I am Iron Man
I am Jewish I am black I am gay I am
disabled but I am gay that's the best
one out of the three I am gay I am
Qatari I am gay I am gay I am a Muslim
today I feel African I am gay
oh this is good man this is
I felt deep bi
people are saying I am I am 1600 DPI
uh so shout out Cuomo I wonder what he's
up to these days hiding in shame I am
making a gay black immigrant disabled
New Yorker
today I am uh disabled
today I am uh I am Jewish Jewish today I
am
gay I am gay just today
okay
enthusi I felt ugly I felt gay I
didn't look like somebody told me oh so
by the way we wrote a speech for the
lookalike and at first we said if we win
let's have him read foosi's verbatim
but I thought that's probably not going
to play well since
not everyone there knows yeah yeah okay
but that but that's just what they told
me writing it all out on paper it made
it extra beautiful to me
when you transcribed uh I thought it was
stunning yeah yeah away with words that
guy it's one of the greatest I feel uh
Jewish I feel that would be a good
speech uh black I was bullied because I
had uh I was a bullied because I had the
Red Hill because I know what it means to
be discriminated dude this [ __ ] guy
he's discriminated for his red hair
today I feel gay
so that's a little treat for you at the
top of the show oh yeah can we show this
at it
there's actually
there's more to your
your theory than yeah I thought here's
Ninja at the Nuremberg trials this is
actionable this is actually an
international uh crime against humanity
dude [ __ ] you Ninja
[ __ ] you we will find you the Israelis
do not forget we will find you the Jews
uh because you know the the Israelis
actually hunted down all the Nazis after
World War II right
that's Auschwitz
well yeah
we didn't cut his tits off don't worry
uh Jordan right he's still got those
nothing serious yeah nothing serious
dude Ninja
I almost changed I almost changed for
him
yeah
I believed in love again and I almost
found it and then it's like you're in
love you believe in love
and then
like the girl you're in love with you
think life can be different she goes and
like [ __ ] your dad damn I'm not
and then you become totally jaded
and it's just war and now my Andrew Tate
fan
I'm playing play what do you said again
like the actual like quote that has us
all upset am I Jewish I'm not
is he sure
kind of sounds a little Jewish from the
way it says that you think so play it
again
am I Jewish am I Jewish
maybe maybe we spoke too soon yeah I
heard he's moving to Argentina to find
Refuge with the other Nazis there
dude what a [ __ ] anti-semite this
dude is basically leading the National
Socialist movement all right
I'm pissed off I'm gonna stop dissing
the Nazis all the time you you forgot
your Nazi flare at home Ninja
there's a lot of things that I love
about Hitler
dude we have so many good sound bites
it's crazy we just came up so big man we
got Kanye talking about Hitler
and people saying he sounds a little
seinfeldy there that's what I'm saying
isn't it like the way he yeah maybe you
should do answer yeah I think he should
maybe do
a 20 take your blood three of me I'm
seeing that he's helped Welsh descent oh
well oh Welsh that's like the they're
white it's the Jews of the British Isles
okay you want to pack that down a little
bit I don't know you sure you wanted to
be out there really
people say Ethan's angry to get ready
for another strike oh I better chill out
take the take the steps away actually
speaking of the stuff oh no no I just
need to chill and take a sip us up
speaking of the subs uh it is time for
the subs
ninja that's that's ninja when he pulls
the lever
play that again Ian ninja's face when he
pulls the lever
ninja is the winner of three streaming
Awards [ __ ] scammed ass stupid ass
award show what did he win biggest Nazi
uh lives
he won what creator of the year live
streamer
uh he won breakout Creator Christmas
dudes killed at a concentration camp in
one month
about Hitler
it looks like he's in a concentration
camp make it up your mind AJ are you in
are you out
I'm not
I'm so pissed that ninja bro mask off I
am Jewish I am Jewish
I need a full apology just insisting in
the background
uh oh and then yeah and then on top of
the attack for Elon simping I've even
forgot about that and
right all right it is funny
and it's not funny it is funny
it's not funny all right let's do that
thank you to gamer sup we love gamer
Subs they are just the best best best
great beverage good people
okay oh wow gamer Subs
is the best drink straight up
I drink it every show and you can tell
that the quality of the show has
improved vastly since I've started gamer
sub I'm energized I have gotten two
strikes probably since we started
but
it's more exciting
it tastes amazing it's got no sugar it's
got caffeine it hydrates it's everything
you would want in a drink
and this keeps me amped up man it's so
good let me hit that
my favorite flavor by the way
is the black cherry this one is just so
good I don't know you guys have you guys
probably have favorite flavors blue res
black cherry you bought you black
chicken baby right yeah
what do you got baby what do you jingle
mango yeah that's my all-time favorite
it's rocking that mango I was gonna say
you guys should listen to love because
he's like a he's a game he's a gamer
yeah he knows what he's talking about
unlike a lot of other brands no need to
name anything this actually blends with
the water completely you you will you
won't have almost any powder when you
drink chunks and other brands yeah you
will have to constantly shake it it um
it lands on the bottom after a while if
you don't shake it that's done
yeah but Gamers up we don't have that
camera stop is a perfectly
perfectly blend
here's the deal guys use code H3 you'll
get 10 off your whole order always
and if you don't believe us pay the five
dollars in shipping and get some free
samples so you can try it and make the
decision for yourself
oh you get free samples you just pay for
shipping that's right at gamersup.gg H3
um
if you're trying to lose weight if
you're hooked to drinking sodas and
stuff this is perfect
this is going to help you lose weight
there's no sugar there's no calories
it's more affordable
and they sponsor us so
that's a big plus too frankly is a huge
Dub yep
you know so
it's frankly a gateway to a healthier
life and I honestly diet drinks have
been saving me during this weight loss
thing because you really get cravings
for sweet things
and um
this kind of stuff saves me man Gamers
up just run to a gamer sub hits the spot
hmm
once it take once again guys gamer sup
gamer sups dot GG slash H3
use the code H3 to get 10 off always
or
uh you can also get a free samples if
you just pay five bucks for the shipping
so check it out links in the description
we love gamer sub thank you so much you
guys for supporting us
love love love love love
people are saying I should make my own
flavor stay tuned stay tuned people we
might be working on something special
with the gamer sup peeps stay tuned
we're in the lab yeah
I was thinking uh elephant jizz they
have like the craziest names elephant
jizz would you guys drink that
I don't think I would no I don't know
Ninja's goo how about flavor and Ninja's
anti-semite I bet that for a flavor
oh yes it's true good point funny
it's not funny all right let's move on
thank you Gamers up we love you
um
let's see yeah
oh guys I so okay you all know I've been
on a weight loss Journey here I don't
know how long I've been going
maybe I can work it out when was this
photo taken
I
um I believe those with idubbbz and he
said let me double check
this was definitely my fattest I
remember this photo and I remember
because this is a 2XL shirt and I
remember being like damn this 2XL is
tight like what the hell well you know
what I was watching a clip from the
interview you guys did with Andrew for
leftovers you looked so different and
that was so recent yeah I think it was
like last month
yes one is seven months ago yeah this
was the seven months ago
holy [ __ ] oh wow so I've been doing this
for longer than I thought
wow that's crazy that's cool that I've
been sticking with it that long kind of
just lose track of time but this is when
I was like 250 and
um you know a lot of the before and
afters people post they're being nice
and I appreciate the support and stuff
but a lot of it could be like oh that's
an angle that's a camera angle it's hard
to tell but this one you really can
so here's fat [ __ ] piece I'm not even
gonna say that because people feel bad
uh here's Ethan big fat okay I can't
even help myself here's Ethan 250
minutes yeah we lay off the fat it's
just an ugly Ethan here she's ugly I
didn't say ugly Dan why are you putting
that up I'm just kidding so here is fat
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I can't help myself
here's Ethan just ugly seven months ago
and then this was Friday look at that
that is a big difference it is that's
crazy that's awesome so I'm that makes
me feel really really um
really happy
yeah no so the shirts are less tight
obviously and things are fitting nicer
and I'm just feeling encouraged and
happy to see that I'm finally making
progress because for the longest time it
felt like progress was impossible and uh
I feel this it's awesome I see a lot of
people commenting on your jawline being
a lot more visible jawline King yay
yes so that that that's actually so nice
to see you know and
proud of you thanks bro I just it's hard
it cuts I was getting really big you
know and I obviously this you can be big
if that's what you're into if that's
you're comfortable with I was not
comfortable I do not like it
you know I would think about it every
night literally every night before bed
like God what am I going to do about
this
and uh that's great man what do they
have about it yeah
also Alden ring was out at that time
juicing that a lot I don't know if that
contributed by
I've was I'm not going to blame this on
Oliver
but she did just have a kid uh right
before this this was a steady thank you
baby thank you this was a steady
collection of mass
and we got weights and Ethan we got to
get those weights out of Ethan Yeah man
so there it is so obviously there's
still a lot of still a lot of work left
to do this was 250.
now I'm at like 222.
my goal is like 180 so I still have like
a [ __ ] long way to go 222 is an angel
number though
angels on my body angels in your body
also Dan made a promise once you get
under 200 if I remember correctly that's
right you can mail it down baby Dan
should mail up that Dome you know that
was uh I think like
probably close to three years ago
yeah maybe two probably two years ago
I probably weighed around 220 when I was
saying that so I'm back to where I was
then I think does that make sense are
you still think I'm bigger than that
I think you were bigger at the time I
think it was like 2 30 you said if I
remember correctly because I think I
remember it being 30 pounds you needed
to lose
you know
oh by the way thank you for the gifted
um
potato salad thank you for the five
gifts appreciate you I love you Mari
thank you for the donut very inspiring
of them struggling with weight and I'm
at my heaviest I've ever been but I
started going to the gym again
and I'm staying committed eating right
you know for me the thing
like I try to exercise every day and I
just walk the treadmill so
I found something that I like and I can
do and it's repeatable because I just
watch anime or something and
um
some days I'm not feeling it you know so
what I'll do is I'll take a lighter I'll
take a lighter walk but what's important
is that I still do it and then when I'm
feeling like energetic I'll crank it up
a little bit but like just saying
consistent I think is the most important
thing
um the food thing is
yeah the one food thing that's really
working for me is that I if I'll eat
whatever I want right and
um
if I want to have a [ __ ] burrito or
eat some wild [ __ ] I just don't eat or
have like a tiny breakfast
and then you could you can go buck wild
and still be at a deficit you know what
I mean you know I I've been waiting wait
this when was this cam found it I
believe this is from the episode
um that we were talking about so yeah H3
weighs himself not good
pokeman's in chat she just joined as a
member and she said oh hey Pokey what'd
you say hi she's trying to sign off the
uh class action yeah oh Pokey are you
here because you want to join the class
action against Ninja because I'm
pressing charges
how many how many how many how much
views did that get a hundred thousand
seven Kim and this was posted on what
date
uh I don't know February 26 2021
February 26th
wow that's crazy yeah so I was
definitely wow yeah so it was almost it
was almost three years ago so I'm
skinnier than that now right yeah whoa
that's crazy Pokey said Ethan's on his
hot girl walk era okay
from one Queen to another
slaying together will be slaying ninja
together I don't know if you want to
talk about that you're free to call him
but yeah I turned on ninja I was trying
to make up to him and I should have
never even tried ninja because all right
she's poking because he did you so dirty
I should have never even gave him the
grace of trying to be his friend thank
you for the gifted Nick she said her
lawyer will be in touch okay fantastic
you know what I mean I betrayed you in a
way by even trying to make up to him but
now I see he's a snake he's a rat he
could never be trusted again and frankly
I feel that he's a threat to my safety
[Music]
look at this psycho he's on meth like
Hitler was
you know that meth was on uh
methamphetamines I don't know if it was
meth it was some sort of amphetamine
yeah it was meth yeah just like Ninja
she said purr let's slay ninja
she said I was trying to warn you in
love
right
dude come on yeah but anyway pokey's
Queen Pokey is life thank you for being
here we love you
friend of the show gotta have you back
on soon we had such a fun time the last
time you were here with us
so anyway I'm really proud of myself you
know good man it's good actually I can
finally say
for the first time in years that I'm
successfully losing weight and yet still
it's not stopping anyone
on the internet from calling me fat
so I I told you I've been following what
you're doing just watching what I eat
and I'm actually down a few pounds as
well good for you bro last night thank
you thank you last night I'm so [ __ ]
pissed on myself because I binged I'm so
[ __ ] mad I'm feeling it today so like
if you do you find if you go above and
beyond a little bit with food that you
feel it the next day
look what I tell myself that I think the
important thing is like
it's a it's a it's a marathon it's not a
Race So if I have bad food days right
and you gotta not be too hard on
yourself you got to remind yourself that
you know
you're gonna make it up with the good
habits you've developed you got to stay
on path and you know it's not about
depriving yourself you can enjoy food
you know what I mean um you can on
holidays and when the family's over like
enjoy yourself all that and um
right just just have faith in the
process you just got to stay true to to
the process and know that it's a
marathon right because I I ate a whole
[ __ ] extra large pizza yesterday
that's pretty bad let's [ __ ] go dude
I'm still bloated what kind of that yeah
that would [ __ ] me up extra large extra
large Crush that whole thing for
yourself wait what was on it cheese and
then uh half I got chicken on the other
half and you did you get it like with
maybe Chantel will have some but then
you could end up eating she got her own
pie oh so you got it with the intention
of crush it all I was hungover as [ __ ]
yesterday yeah so I'm like oh my God I
need carbs I need carbs like I was it
was bad the night before it was bad
um but yeah you I mean listen yeah you
[ __ ] up but it's just one meal you
know what I mean you gain you gain
weight by making bad choices for a long
time right right it's one meal you're
probably gonna ship most of it out I I
believe me I did yeah so you're fine
yeah
I'm jealous I can't have pizza anymore
since I've stopped eating gluten my life
has been [ __ ] hell hell wait wait I
thought it was supposed to help you what
do you mean what do you mean your life's
been held just eat the bread I mean it's
been hell that I can't eat anything I
just had gluten-free bread sucks guys it
tastes like garlic the bread you said
we're happier before
but then I then I die internally but it
was that bad it was really bad my face
would get so hot my ears would get hot
and I was like unbearable AC yeah so
what's better so what's better fans we
got these little what's the problem
on Friday yeah
you ate a massive Burrito on Friday the
bread was thin but yeah no I knew going
into that that uh it could potentially
uh cause some uh follow-up but it wasn't
bad after that what about super thin
crust pizza
I don't know there's gluten-free pieces
yeah there's some gluten-free pizzas are
okay what about cauliflower like that
gluten-free bread and I went to Whole
Foods and bought a bunch of gluten-free
stuff and holy [ __ ] that's expensive
well they will rip you off
gluten-free bread is not it's not good
it expires in four months what the hell
does that tell you yeah that's just
that's just delicious do you like do you
like cauliflower crust is that
gluten-free that is gluten free yeah
that shit's good really good yeah
cauliflower crust the pre-frozen ones
yes the CPK ones are very good too go
CPK then we tried it once on the show
and we did yeah that was the first time
I ever had it and I was surprised by how
uh acceptable it was all right listen
we're not being we're not getting paid
by big cauliflower all right come on
let's move on but we could be reach out
yes so big colleague
give me a call Colleen besides being you
know losing weight and being at like a
two-year low on weight
this video Someone posted on the
subreddit from like three days ago Ethan
Klein back at again fat I'm back at it
again being fat
yeah I didn't I didn't apologize today
by the way for being fat guys I meant to
do that at the top of the show so
apologize the thumbnail rules it's like
is that supposed to make you look bad
because it just kind of makes you look
awesome you look good in that picture
and that that's the set again we can't
win that's the segment I did to try to
prove to all the alphas that I'm Alpha
right I got in the ice top bath I smoked
a cigar I ate a ground beef burger and
that's when we thought liver King was
natural by the way so I'm more Alpha
than he is
true true and then it's like oh fat okay
dude back at it again
[Music]
oh and then someone at the award show
yesterday the host called me ugly
right that was what I was referencing
when I said ugly Ethan by the way that
wasn't just okay out of the blue yeah he
called me this host of this
[ __ ] show went up there and
called my ass ugly right
so we'll get to that you know what I
mean I'm being I'm being
I'm like Ukraine up in this I'm taking
it from
got fronts on many sides we got Russia
we got uh who's those [ __ ] to the
north of uh
Belarus yeah yeah [ __ ] that president
yeah yeah welcome ninja like
[ __ ] anyone I hate now is ninja
that dude's like Ninja
can he [ __ ]
hit the gritty after cleaning up
cleaning up a squad though is that the
gritty
that's the gritty
[ __ ]
yes yeah yeah oh yeah you got it you got
it you got it you got it I can grid I
can hit the grid you can hit the grit
yeah listen I know he's an anti-semite I
know he was allied with the Nazis uh
when he was working for Imperial Japan
in the 1940s but man can that guy shoot
a shoddy yeah well I was just listening
to the Daily today and it turns out
Russia actually hit the grid really hard
uh Russia or Ukraine has no power so
he's hit in the grid literally
Vladimir Putin we have a
oh yeah we have a little image of uh Sam
as Ninja
breaking news okay that's yeah she's
hitting the grid by the way tell you she
cannot wear that out anymore because
that's basically like wearing ninja
Flair our Nazi flare listen
but I don't think you're I don't think
you're turning salmon Ian against Ninja
there's Stan so let me ask you this Ian
are you a Nazi sympathizer yes or no
well first so Sam yeah she I gotta call
her because I think she's at the grocery
store with that on right now that
costume so I'll have to call her yeah
I mean it's not safer to walk around
like that no I I I I have pulled back on
the ninja because well I think what has
to happen is like you know when like
Nick Cannon started getting on that like
anti-semitic stuff and they send him to
go talk to a rabbi yeah and also Kanye
got invited to the Holocaust Museum so I
think maybe you have to send ninja
somewhere to just really reflect on what
he did and then maybe we could you know
heal from them that's a good idea where
should we send uh Ninja well wasn't
there like a holocaust remember uh
Memorial in Fort diet
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's make ninja walk that [ __ ] on
stream because yeah I think I think the
the punishment should fit the crime and
you know in the the spectrum of
anti-Semitism ninja is definitely less
than like what Kanye's done so so some
sort of uh virtual metaverse tour
estimatable yeah Hannah by the way says
a token appreciation from Belarusian uh
fupa Trooper okay we love the Belarusian
people
just the president over there it's kind
of a dick but you know what wait I know
a lot of people are counting Kanye out
but he's going to Aidan Ross's stream
and maybe Aiden could uh help change him
over help yeah I'm sure Aiden's the one
to uh speak truth to Kanye oh God can we
he didn't be like yeah the Jews are kind
of like that aren't they they're not
going to
that clip of him in real time
discovering what fascism was can you
link that yeah I think I should watch
that I don't know that that's real
because you think he's playing dumb
everybody's giving him way too much
credit I feel because yeah no I don't
think he was playing around love is
tried to say that Aiden plays up his
stupidity for views it's probably a mix
right like he is dumb and then he plays
it up to fool people that he's not dumb
to put some doubt maybe but like maybe
if you played if you played dumb for
like years and years you become dumb it
becomes a reality
yeah I don't know you guys got to watch
this clip of him trying to understand
what's fascism
so he's perfectly equipped to have a
nuanced discussion with Kanye about
anti-semitism
you got this you want me to open it I
got it I got it I got it thank you
um let's see stay in your [ __ ] Lane
us on Saturday
does a fastest mean fastest
is he sure I mean come on you can't be
that dumb he did he is he a high school
graduate you know what I mean I mean is
he like he got popular really young I
think so I think he must some of these
kids they they get they blow up can he
read 17 and well a third grade reading
level
he went to high school in Florida my
cousins graduated there it's not saying
a lot no no is he alumni though did he
graduate let me see
um it means you are
a far-right authorization isn't he
Jewish yes yeah he's yeah this guy needs
to he is Jewish
and he needs to take this a little bit
more seriously because Kanye actually
wants to like round your ass up bro
yes he graduated okay he's a great guy
he's a graduate so you can't be that
dumb in like graduate high school I know
that's well let's watch let's watch
analyst political ideology no he's not
that dumb Ultra nationalist
ultraanalyst
oh I guess he graduated from California
not Florida I was mistaken huge L for
our state [ __ ] dictator leadership
centralized autocracy militarism for
forcible suppression suppression of
opposition so I don't know what that
means but I swear to God I don't know
what the [ __ ] a fascism is I don't know
what the [ __ ] that is
Benito mazzuli and jivionate genital and
Jason Stanley like who the [ __ ] are
these people bro never heard of my
[ __ ] life what is an example of a
fastest
yo all right bro see what I'm saying
chat like this is why I don't [ __ ] with
y'all bro like dude like this is what
the [ __ ] I don't bro I don't [ __ ] with
y'all bro wait you can't show Hitler on
the screen and chat or something
no I think he just didn't realize that
it doesn't have anything to do with
Nazis so I think he just he thinks he
knows
right yeah
can I be honest of course always no if
someone came at me maybe
six months ago I would not be able to
give a good definition of flashes you
know
I know right it's like right something
bad that's what I know it's hard to
Define so I but like so it's not that
that's still hotly debated to this day
yeah people are still like trying to
decide what fascism means but surely you
knew that Nazis were fascists right love
yeah yeah I assume so I I'm I'm with
love that's good on my extent and I knew
Nazis were involved to be honest I mean
I've been trying to figure out what does
fascism mean for a while it's hard to
pin down but
it's far right authoritarian they have a
dictator they control the media they
control the means of uh production they
basically are at War usually uh and uh
they're controlled by Propaganda it's
like a it's like you know man the
barricades
uh it's hard to explain it is hard to
explain frankly
mm-hmm
Chad is agreeing with me there's a
couple of swimmers in shot that agrees
with me but we all know that the Nazis
are the quintessential fascists and we
love them for that and nothing else
I thought it was just about being
stylish yeah fascism by the way I
disavow Kanye and Hitler and I'm Jewish
and they're both wrong
our La our leftovers episode last week
got demonetized
we were talking about Kanye uh on Alex
Jones and I said why because it's a news
show I figured we could be able to talk
about that stuff
they said you played Nick Fuentes
clip for too long without
disavowing it I said the [ __ ]
so you didn't disavow Nick Fuentes for
this uh I was like you are you so you
know YouTube's got some crazy
[ __ ] rules
it's like y'all crazy that whole episode
is us talking about what a
[ __ ] stay Nick Fuentes is I've made a
few sons of [ __ ] I made a lower third
to throw on the screen now too to really
hammer it in that we disavowed our
disclaimer that you asked oh yeah let me
see that yeah well it's not rendered yet
I'll show you after the show yeah I
asked the guys to make a uh disclaimer
for whenever we talk about like Nazi
[ __ ] and to say I don't I disavow we do
not believe
uh
it's it's crazy but there it is they go
they go if you just play the clip
without disavowing it it's the same as
you re-uploading it I was like
okay it'll be something like this but it
will be animated with this dumbass alert
we disavowed everything said by this
loser that's awesome the siren's been
around oh that's actually see I like
this this is actually good yeah try and
make it at least a little funny so it's
not so like why the [ __ ] are they
showing and the siren and the sirens
will be animated yeah yeah I love that
love that love that thank you Kim
just to really spell it out for YouTube
yep yeah dear YouTube uh Hall Monitor
yeah so there's that
um
I guess we should probably get into the
steamies yeah
but there's so many good stuff at the
top of the show
for example this pair of paramedic fail
I've seen this one it's it's a good one
man it's good a pair so
it just got posted to our sub and I had
to throw it in there uh
you know what's crazy this lady falls
kind of Grace is Grace gracefully like
watch her she hits like a really nice
role look at that [ __ ] it looks like
fairly comfortable I feel like does a
Dark Souls roll he did some
um
what do you call the damn thing the
Michael Scott parkour oh he's parkour's
out yeah
yeah but that's not good planning why
did the driver like bone out he like
sped the [ __ ] off well it's an emergency
I sure what it sure is an emergency
in one gear go something she's got
debilitating back
yeah someone's got to get the second
girl on that Gurney
man
what country is this I wonder it's just
the back of a pickup truck [ __ ]
oh damn that's funny
they weren't ready this dude just failed
bro you're not in an ambulance dude
you're in the back of a pickup truck and
the trailer's open
yo she's graceful as [ __ ] though the
lady holding her hand no
she's ready to go boom
yeah unfortunately she did pass away no
I'm just kidding I don't know I I she's
fine you can see she sits up a lot of
people in the chat saying it's uh Mexico
and it's a classic meme in Mexico
[Laughter]
she see she even puts her head up she's
fine
yeah no problem you fixed her actually
yeah they popped it back into place yeah
this is how they you're back in Mexico
the chiropractor driving yeah no offense
to Mexico uh we love Mexico but
one time my family was on a trip to
Mexico my brother uh
slipped and injured his elbow and had to
get stitches and after it got treated he
got so infected he almost had to have
his arm amputated I didn't oh holy [ __ ]
yeah no offense to Mexican medicine but
uh
it was it was hard it was a rough time
my brother went from having like a
scrape on his elbow and then he got so
infected that once he went back home
he his arm was in like sepsis or
something I don't know what it is but
yeah they almost had to amputate it they
had to give him like experimental insane
levels of antibiotics first diagnosis
delusional so I came home and went to
bed
right
well no he hurt his elbow but I
everybody's uh
yeah it's definitely Mexico
from the comments that I'm saying
I'm sorry oh [ __ ]
thank you
okay
we love our Mexican neighbors uh
beautiful I really do love Mexico so
much
oh my God there's just so much at the
top of the show to get to but Cameron
went on a twitch streamers this [ __ ] was
crazy oh
so this is um her I guess her name is
sup Caitlin can I give the backstory
here yeah I'd love to back okay yeah so
I mean a lot of the time at night when
I'm sketching I throw on Twitch streams
because like I like to you know just
have background noise or whatever and
this popped up when I was scrolling
through just chatting I was like this is
fascinating because all the people
um that go on the show are
kind of like the kind of folks that I
would see on my Tick Tock feed so
um just like very interesting dudes to
say the least and I figured what the
[ __ ] I'll I'll get in the queue there
and I didn't think I would get through
and I I just wanted to you know goof
around and uh I somehow got through
you got through and um she didn't seem
happy with your performance right and
also I gotta say I didn't drop this on
our group chat because I thought I was
boring and cringe so if you find me
boring and cringe you were Chad as [ __ ]
because she probably expects everyone
who calls in to worship her I'll be like
oh oh you're so beautiful
don't do anything you want mistress and
that's kind of how it goes on the show
too I love watching that show just for
the the dudes
cam bought that jacket after this stream
he was feeling like a boss no no come on
it is it's a cozy jacket though okay so
this is a sup Caitlyn is she a big
streamer I'm sorry Caitlin I just I
don't know
yeah okay yeah and I didn't realize this
at the time but I guess her and Hassan
Upstream together in the past and oh I
heard that there's actually good Hassan
Lord where she said she was interested
in hooking up with the son or that she
found him attractive and then she went
over to his house to and he just like
showed her political videos for like 12
hours and she left
like I was reading in the chat they
watched Joe Rogan together I guess oh
yeah they watched Joe Rogan together
yeah that's I didn't realize
yeah like he blew it oh [ __ ] yeah that's
fine at least he didn't have any Bongos
that's what the [ __ ] reminds me of
that story yeah I don't know yeah the
only thing worse would be Bongos yeah
I don't know if anyone has the lore on
that but man I can't watch it I'm
cringing already well here it is Cameron
meets
super Caitlyn
oh there's no audio [ __ ] God damn it
I've seen they did a male streamer tier
list together Hassan and her mail
streamer tier list yeah was he included
in that
uh
[Music]
let me see
how you gonna put your own self enough
yeah he's he's uh I just fast forward to
the end of the video he's at the S tier
hey whoa why'd they get dragged into
that room
oh you do kind of and your voice too
thanks whoa yeah you do she's right what
you look like Morgan's critical do you
know what that is Charlie oh yeah yeah I
just like him
dude you're so shocked
hold on
there was a room of like 50 people in
the waiting room in VC and then in voice
chat and then I got dragged into like a
separate room so I'm guessing one of her
mods recognized my username or something
and then put me in this like separate
room
and uh that's the call uh for the show
right the separate room no there was
like a completely separate room that
like I don't even know like it was just
different from okay all right yeah you
seem totally shocked to be here yeah
because like there's a bunch of people
in the Discord Archer for the prime and
thank you a Ross for five dollars you
guys see it too right it's literally him
it's literally me
voice Cameron
wait someone says you're from the E
Street cam from E Street podcast
it's just the show just a show what
would you have said I know I'm just
number one podcast in the world yeah
it's better I'm a big deal lady okay
next time I'm on a dating show you
better recognize I'm Cameron
it's just a show okay
Trail yeah exactly that's me famous and
Rich so what are you doing
famous and rich just from a show baby
oh yeah honestly I was uh browsing
through the just chatting I saw you
there and I thought it was funny and I
just uh joined out of a as a goof are
you horny is that why uh no not yet not
yet okay after this she's trying to get
you bro but you're not you're just
chatted out I'm looking for friendship
in all the wrong places what can I say
yeah yeah so so you were okay you joined
for a goof yeah she probably took that
as a slight she's like what you don't
wanna
you don't want to look at my um rest
well I mean no
this is her uh I mean that's what it is
right this is the [ __ ] and she'll ask
questions like that because like I mean
a lot of the times like people don't
have great social skills that will call
initialize that and it kind of like
makes them squirm it makes me squirm and
uh I don't know I just uh
that's just their stick people in were
salty in in the Reddit replies but
that's just their stick I thought it was
funny
should be
what the call yeah
yeah
oh yeah you keep calling her dude and
she said she that annoys her too sorry
dude
love that
dude yeah you're not you're not
expressing interest you just chatted out
bro
you'd have to ask him I'm not Charlie
dude dude okay what is your sexual
fantasy cam
that's me um I don't know man you can
hear my voice go up because this is when
I get nervous I uh I don't know if I'm
prepared to say in front of a 2014 uh
420 will you tell us your sexual fantasy
now in front of 43 000 camera no I'm not
vanilla dude yeah
just missionary sure let's go with that
and that's vanilla sure yeah it's fine
I'm not gonna press you it's not that
type of show no definitely not it's just
some shows just some show it's just a
show
you're a man of people dude
you have a weird fetish huh that's why
you can't I don't know
I just met you dude we gotta take it
slow dude
big enough man small see the way the
answer says a lot about them if you're
scared to show your sexual fantasy that
means like you're into some weird ass
[ __ ] you can't you're addicted I'm shy
dude I'm just shy dude
I'm vanilla as [ __ ] you know I'm not not
entertaining you know
okay all right thank you very much I
appreciate that yeah you know I just I
don't know just having a good time
vibing on the chat right now oh I'm
looking for a friend more than anything
oh you can be my friend like
uh well you know I'm gonna friendzone
you for now we'll start something
wow come on I'm Chadron you just friend
zoned the girl in the bra that's that's
just how I take things I just take it
slowly take it slow man bro get to know
each other a little bit
now you're Chadron stop oh thank you
thank you Chad Ethan all right how you
ask me questions then so I can the
unsoluble Cameron
all right ah [ __ ]
you know I I don't really know
um
how's your night going you have a good
night uh honestly
honestly I've been on here tonight have
been super weird like actually I noticed
that yeah
gosh I wonder why the guy right before
me was a 45 year old guy that sounded
like a mountain man and he couldn't
figure out how to turn on his cameras
I mean who does she expect to call in
you know she's sitting there and abroad
like 3 A.M
just taking random cues on Discord I'm
not expecting the
great show it's an amazing
it's an amazing show I love it that's an
amazing show this is just some show this
is just some show yeah and [ __ ] too you
know Obama needs [ __ ] too you gotta
have them ribs dude that is so racist
bro stop
gotta have them ribs you gotta remove
that one bro
I hope nothing no am I wrong
it's just funny okay all right leave it
I hope not to join that uh that haul but
you know I think we're having fun go in
my hole you son
no I hope not to join that Hall of weird
have you tried both holes before or just
one hole or zero holes no comment dude
I'm shy about time
you won't give her anything then anyway
it's actually six minutes so yeah we
don't gotta watch the whole thing you
got you get the gist let uh let me see
you say goodbye we're very invasive but
it was nice meeting you
no you know I'm sorry I'm very shy but I
hope you had a good time talking and I
hope you had a great time but thank you
for coming that's fine thanks for having
me have a great night there it is
I thought he would know my questions
because I've been asking the same [ __ ]
all night right but I don't think he
wanted to answer so I'll just let him
leave yeah thank you Cam for being on
here I do appreciate it and thanks for
having me podcast person okay so so so
inamicable ending to a thought it went
great you have a new friend yeah exactly
I think you should probably maybe she'll
reach out to you now for for some
friendship after this that'd be cool I
mean yeah it's safe to say Cupid's
arrows weren't flying that night for
either of us thanks for having me on the
show it's you you run a great show it
was very funny and uh yeah thanks
these are great bud thank you my fetish
she goes what's your sexual fetish my
fetish is [ __ ] on ladies toes and
watching them squish it between their
toes dude that's the type of people
answer that [ __ ] I mean I not to that
degree but folks would answer like that
and you know my hat's off to you for
being so bold on such a public forum to
those guys well you're not Anonymous
like they are I don't know who you are I
kind of underestimate the the reach of
the show because you know immediately as
soon as I joined the whole chat with
Spam and H3 [ __ ] and uh oh wow yeah
that's cool I love this stuff out there
we love H3 men they're out there
everywhere
something [ __ ] Bradley Martin's Tick
Tock comments
the one place we need you
Ninja's a [ __ ] Nazi
one more before we get into the main
segment Jamie Lee's wild in on Insta we
we like this one Jimmy Lee is back in H3
Studios a b get me some camel milk on
the rocks
and a Viagra for Danny Boy
yep he's been posting bangers lately
let's see this one was good really good
[Music]
Source the voice is in my head
it's actually a [ __ ] joke
it's a common Motif too
um
this one was pretty interesting where'd
they find I've never even seen this
photo where'd they get this day oh I'm
not it's a manipulated photo as you can
probably imagine
Oh I thought it was real is that oh it
looks so real holy [ __ ] I thought that
would they got just like a young photo
of you no I was like damn you took a
selfie earlier I never had hair like
that no so proud of my son Dan Lee
passing his driver test today can we get
some lands in chat here's of course uh
Jay Leno uh crashing
and uh
yeah proud dad is dead is that Bobby's
her
no I don't think so I don't think so
back it off this one this one actually
pissed you off cam with the commissioner
creating fomo dude I [ __ ] hate Roger
you know [ __ ] you Roger Goodell I know
you're watching eat [ __ ] Roger Goodell I
agree with that
looks like he painted his hairline on
the Roger Goodell so he texts me these
photos and I immediately sent it to our
our chat and there was a side profile
one that his hairline is so bad whoa
look at that one like the paint why
Jimmy dude he goes out like that Jimmy
you can't go out like that it's so much
worse
it looked worse than this
no I'm saying it looks worse him doing
that than not you know yeah like if he's
doing like Street comedy doing his [ __ ]
whatever I get it but like going out
like this with your family dude
it's funny this is like the first post
that's real but somehow he made it look
fake in the first in the first photo
look at this
look at that
dude you can't be serious with that you
know Jimmy everybody knows what you're
doing like Gary Oldman and Dracula dude
like swear straight up it's just no
you're not everybody look is like just
looking at your hairline it's not it's
not good do you think he keeps those
sunglasses in his back pocket wherever
he goes for sure he's bust him out for
the photos
for sure
this guy's I got somebody said he looks
like RoboCop without the mask on
I never remember can you pull up a
picture Murphy
the hairline hairline
yeah so that's kind of a good thing
RoboCop hairline's kind of far look at
that [ __ ] that's awesome I gotta find
who said that I just briefly saw it and
fly by in the chat oh that's funny
that's good man you just know there's
gonna be RoboCop memes on his page now
oh yeah I'm pretty sure oh that's good
hold it
so there it is the
The Merchant of venom
where art thine camels sir Abdullah
I didn't see this one's first time yo
The Merchant of Venom hey but you know I
spell my name right no one spells my
name right so Abdullah he nailed it I
love how it's just all H3 related memes
well dude I'm telling you whoever makes
these memes is like an absolute meme
genius it's on it's Mason
look at this [ __ ] oh that that's the one
yeah that's okay you cannot
you reviewed these pictures you gotta
stop you gotta stop you hit it with that
that double Just For Men man you just
listen man we did a bit we did the
special episode with my dad and him and
we did like goofy hairlines that's what
we did on him yeah well that's wearing
it for real now that's what Olivia was
saying she's like oh my God he liked my
work so much yeah continuing on with it
he liked what I did for him
beautiful
I love that one I'm coming out as
fomosexual yeah that one's good I
appreciate him joining
the lgbtq plus homosexual
see this looks much better I mean
I mean it's a normal hairline he does
yeah it's better than putting [ __ ]
you know polish on your hair bro
it's just not
at least he uses a straight edge you
know why not just get a toupee at that
point just right get a haircut he pays
like thousands and thousands of dollars
a month on the ship bro he is paying
someone this did
just get a hair dude
surgery like he can afford that right I
think he's too old he doesn't I don't
think he has enough hair for it to work
I see I mean he's 80 years old you know
there's only you know so much you can do
I think genuinely he should get a hair a
hair piece there the hair pieces of
getting so freaking good I see some guys
on tick tock yeah they look amazing I
don't know but do you think he needs a
tube though like like a tube like a
toupee well do you like the paint
if if it's such a big deal I don't think
he needs it but if it's so important to
him that he's willing to walk around
with paint on his head then maybe yeah
maybe it's a better option I think it
looks fine but yeah you just wear a hat
too I mean
if it really bothers him that much he'd
look sick in like a kangal or some [ __ ]
like that I love this one detention why
haven't you fixed your comedy I forgore
I forgore
[Applause]
I don't get it
it's just a ship yeah it's an old-timey
joke
I forgot but it's it's wrong that is
also wrong it's like a deep fried meat
okay okay it's a button on the joke
you can only choose one what is your
choice pain of discipline pain of regret
wow
that's deep yeah did some Sigma mail
stuff right there he could also wear a
bandana I know someone that does that
right right right that's true that'd be
good luck and just the whole Outlaw
aesthetic you know and just like the
other guy he's an old guy trying to look
young so you know it works for him
oh [ __ ] we hide your girls me and my son
are on the prowl
[Music]
that makes sense okay what do you think
about
um Pete going with the Jimmy Lee
hairline
like one day yeah one I mean he did this
no he went out like this listen to Jimmy
Lee
I like it wow okay he can't do no wrong
it's a good luck on him yeah
all right I think there it is it's okay
we know you love him
you're not the only one
nothing be embarrassed about
all right so
um let's move on yeah the streamies we
were there we got them good
I actually need to pee though [ __ ] let
me go pee real fast before we start okay
I'll be right back just 10 seconds
sounds good well you're gone I'm gonna
give the people what they want are you
ready
3200 to DPI
that's right
1 600 DPI [ __ ]
800 DPI
let's go all the way up in 200 DPI you
hear that no I heard it
that's spicy it's getting spicy okay uh
one more time because I gotta turn it
down because I can't use my mouse around
800 DPI thank you that's definitely the
most sensual one too
DPS that's posted on the sub earlier
that like months ago they heard a little
snippet and Ethan goes what was that and
the caption was like was that Mr DPI
okay so I saw that too and I was
confused because that did sound like him
but it wasn't said that yeah it wasn't
it was like congratulations it sounded
like some like super popular mobile ad
or something can you find that post I'm
sorry James we gotta analyze this a
little bit I hope our studio is haunted
already all kinds of hunks
what a good problem to have
I got it Evie donates two dollars or 250
euros said Dan did you lose all your
hair on your head
it's on my jacket now I mean yeah Cam's
jackets made of Dan's hair is this news
say it like maybe they're maybe they're
a new viewer maybe they're they're
unaware of my condition
uh no uh in case they're asking
seriously no I did not lose all the hair
on my head just some of it and so I
decided to start shaving my head because
I felt it look better that way so that's
that's the real answer
you can start spraying it I mean I could
grow it out I just you know I got like
the
we call it the yamaka spot in my family
I remember little back of the head uh
bald spot and then you know it's receded
a decent amount in the front too so
I just said [ __ ] it
hi Dan love you well thank you thank you
Erica
thank you so much you look right bald I
feel like I look right bald yeah some
people look right bald and you're one of
those yeah I mean I probably would have
done it earlier but I was genuine I was
kind of afraid to do it because some
people when they shave their head it
doesn't help and their heads are a
little oddly shaped but I don't know I
have
wanted to brag but you've got the right
head I'm into a brag but I got a nice
round head
if you're losing it just embrace it
it's distinguished yeah I was I was I
was happy with my decision you look
great thank you
and we love you for that
how do I gift Subs uh I don't think you
can on mobile if that's uh
if that's where you're at
some people don't think it's enabled on
on an iPhone all right let's get to the
main segment here everyone's been
waiting for
yes I sent an impersonator to the
Streamys because [ __ ] that show I ain't
going to that [ __ ] I knew they weren't
gonna I knew we weren't gonna win we
never went it's our fifth time being
nominated
we never win we get no respect
unbelievable
and um I'm glad I didn't go
you know what I mean this is a [ __ ]
event
really an insult to win to be honest
by the way Hassan won news
[Music]
and actually I'm I'm happy for his song
by the way we weren't even nominated for
show of the year I know we're in
podcasts but like
I feel this is a show
Am I Wrong
um well let's look at these other ones
challenge accepted don't know what that
is chicken shop date don't know what
that is good mythical morning yeah I
would say our show is a little more akin
to a good mythical morning the way they
do
segments and hot ones yeah I mean
obviously there's like different
obviously it's a longer form but
I think of it more of a show but okay
whatever they gave us
Hassan was nominated but uh this guy won
I don't know much about him but Everyone
likes him so obviously good for you
um
yada yada I'm looking for music at the
bottom oh you know what's [ __ ] up too
they yada yada
podcast of the year they didn't even
present the award
yeah that was pretty
like during a commercial break they're
just like oh and shout out to podcaster
of the year uh call me Daddy call me dad
with like 11 other winners too in
different categories like why yada yada
podcast that seems like an important
category
I didn't know we won in the room yeah I
was you guys texted me and that's how I
found out
everyone in in the group chat was like
yo the rig [ __ ] and Ian's like wait
what happened and he's there
so they didn't play that video package
in the room
unless I missed it but uh no I don't
think so weird so imagine if I went
there just to lose like that like that's
just right you wouldn't have known
that's when they announced that Hassan
won and I'm pretty sure he tweeted like
wait I won yeah they did they so he
didn't know either yeah
and by the way this is the guy who
started a war with me a rack more like
just whack
a-rat more like just whack air wreck
arack
era
got it about to invade you like Iraq
work with me
work with me people
it's a good one
um
also a variety streamer I feel like I'm
a variety streamer why am I not a
variety streamer
not enough variety all right so here's
podcast this is ours
Jay Shetty was at least he didn't win
yeah that's probably devastating if I
lost again to Jay Shetty I I don't think
I could handle it yeah
impulsive us and call her daddy which is
a Spotify exclusive it's not even on
YouTube
okay
call her these not I mean no hate to
call me daddy girls
but don't you think it's a little
disrespectful like I'm gonna go there
and get yada yadded and lose during a
commercial break and sit there like an
idiot and not even know what the [ __ ]
happened well they didn't have time they
needed to make time for
the comedy stylings of arak
Iraq listen and I don't know much about
the host but that man was a was a
[ __ ] train wreck on stage boy that
[ __ ] was embarrassing and I'm not even
saying that because he called me ugly
thanks Steph for the gift did I I
genuinely it was very hard to watch like
what I I just think they should hire
they're kind of [ __ ] because they're
like if we hire a professional from
outside then it's like what are we doing
here
but if they hire a an influencer then
it's horrible
they should have hired you the best of
both worlds I would have crushed that
[ __ ]
but they don't respect me yeah
you know what I mean
but the good news is that Gordon Ramsay
won an award for crossover
what yeah I don't know
yeah podcast scripted series
animated me Canyon one that's I like me
Canyon okay
uh dub yeah that's a dub
um where's this damn news category that
Hassan one yeah I'm trying to find the
news one the news one was actually
really cool here it is dude Hassan One
news and destroyed Philip DeFranco I
texted Hassan last night I said yo bro
congrats I'm so glad you beat Philly
uh yeah so so congrats to Hassan uh also
it is a little bit homophobic that gay
news didn't win that but uh I won't call
his son out
yeah you can't keep getting away with it
I felt gay
anyway let's get on to the segment
because this [ __ ] is lame
so we found this uh
go ahead let's just watch let's just
watch the the video
you want me to roll it we saw the fake
Ethan no hold on one sec
yeah this is my favorite thing we showed
you guys these already but this is under
Getty Images under Ethan Klein this is
me
and where do we get this suit Sam or Ian
if she's not here
I think she got it off Amazon and then
she bedazzled the back dude she did an
awesome job of dazzling that it actually
looks so legit
the suit really fits him like a glove
perfect yeah custom-made
which in all honesty is probably the
most Ethan detail of this whole thing
yeah
last time you think I'd show up that
[ __ ] up looking probably was he
wearing slides or no just dress shoes
he's yeah he's he's got vans on or some
[ __ ] next year slides yeah yo but this
steamies bedazzling is the highest
budget detail in that whole damn
broadcast so
should have showed that
um
and so
here is what I posted oh yeah I was I
was trying to gag everyone
I really wanted everyone to think I was
there because I don't think
I I don't think that they give a war I
think they tell people ahead of times
because
at first I was like can you tell us
ahead of time so I can like plan based
up they said we don't tell people ahead
of time but all the people or the
majority of people that went up there
seemed like coached and very tight and I
just I I don't know what do you what's
your take on that there was one girl who
went up and she genuinely seemed
surprised and she was like I have no
idea what to say and I also know that
the year that Tana won Creator she
talked about how she like had no idea
that was gonna happen she was pissed
about like the outfit she was wearing
and stuff I guess none of us did that
still kind of baffles me thank you
uh actually somebody in the chat uh
pointed out if you go back to the list
of winners and go to the podcast
category and click on the H3 podcast
yeah it takes you to something kind of
interesting
um here I'll pull it up right curious
what'd you think about this so wait I
clicked this yeah
they
uh type
games to horses and what draw them in
quarters and rip them apart
why what the [ __ ] it's a timestamped
y'all are weird for that one
does other people go to Times that's
crazy
and when I was me everyone jumped out I
was like really like [ __ ] scared of who
put this together at the beginning of a
video
y'all are weird
is it rigged
Mr uh this guy's this guy has a this
[ __ ] I don't know who this guy
is so no hate but this guy who was
nominated has they've linked to a video
with 60 views on video
what the hell a little odd so no hate
obviously but what the hell dude
Mr Ballin does anyone know who he is
and so as Skyler is driving this boat
Alonso and John are down I'm the 61st
person to watch this
the bedroom I mean but after which is
like good if like you know he has almost
seven million Subs subscribers on
YouTube maybe this was a by like the 60s
how'd they even find this then it's very
odd I don't know what to make of that
weird bro let's see what Jay Shetty gets
hey I don't often do this but lots of
volume uh fans in here
in the in our Channel okay we love
baller he be balling love Mr Ballin I
have big balls we got Big Balls balling
what do you how you guys y'all better
hate Chetty he's my enemy yeah no he's
the worst I don't care about Shetty he's
the [ __ ] worst yeah so I wanted to
convince everyone I was there
so I said so honored to be nominated at
the stream East and to be here in person
I had Ian's feeding me
pick so it looked like I was there
thank you streamies yes it's such an
honor to be nominated
I do not consent Ian was sending me
pictures about notification of filming I
said I don't consent
I wasn't even there
how was the foodie and they just sent
you like they just give you some
desserts like what else did you get
there uh well we were recording the
whole time so I didn't get to eat but
there was catering
um but then this cheesecake was on every
table great cheesecake oh it was good
very good okay all right I probably
would have loved that mm-hmm
hmm Mister on the cheesecake
and then this [ __ ] guy just called me
ugly blown the warhorn
which we'll get to that obviously
livid fuming we lost it's all over Ian
was sending me pictures from a seat and
by the way they seated us far as [ __ ]
and I was like oh hell no we definitely
are not winning they put your ass in
like the back
all the all the other nominees were like
in the front row and they put my s in
the [ __ ] like back dude what was that
[ __ ]
there's no respect
didn't really seem like you were in the
back
yeah towards the middle right
yeah maybe in the middle but
if you're not in the front row you're in
the back row you know what I mean
it's all about clout in this industry
Dan you wouldn't understand
uh so anyway once we lost and I was
pissed I said [ __ ] you streamers I
didn't even go to that [ __ ] I sent this
actor appended to be me
and Ian of course Legend
this Jay Shetty he's my enemy
finally saw what he looks like he looks
like a nice guy he actually looks like
me isn't that weird kind of he's got a
gray hairline more than it's kind of you
guys kind of share her maybe we should
make a ball together
do you see it
instead of me he's my best friend
enemies
[ __ ] the Streamys bro here's my boy
Bizarro Ethan flipping off uh what looks
to be Jay Shetty I think it is [ __ ] the
Streamys [ __ ] it's the steamies this
year y'all
and of course I did finally win an award
biggest hit or ass [ __ ]
swept that award
absolutely swept it so
what was your what was the vibe check on
the night there Ian overall like the
what was what was it like in the room
uh room started strong maybe 10 minutes
in faded fast yeah and they were
starting to announce nominees and
there'd be like two people at like not
exaggerating two people in the room that
would
and it was very it was a little weird
they would drown it out with all this
like you know bed music but the
enthusiasm was not the cheesecake was
not holding everyone over I'd say yeah
yeah it was just a small piece I noticed
really yeah yeah probably worked through
that fast was that
to be shared amongst the whole table too
everyone gets one bite everyone everyone
had a cheesecake plate and actually the
impersonator I think he took three
plates he was my man yeah yeah I mean
you got it
come on Ian
I'm on a diet
um
I'm glad he had fun and I'm glad he he
had a good time
I'm definitely going to send him out
into the world to do all the work I'm
gonna send them to weddings birthday
parties yeah
it'd be awesome
braces
teacher conference teacher conferences
jury duty jury duty why not [ __ ] it
my parents on Friday
so did this get claimed what whatever
happened with that cam
it didn't when we uploaded but let me
just double check real quick
yeah and then the streamers are such
[ __ ] losers that even this brief clip
of this guy calling me ugly is getting
claimed like you're an award show for
influencers and you're saying
nobody gets to watch this [ __ ] nobody
watch this or I'm clean like you [ __ ]
it's insane you literally don't know
what you're doing they claimed anything
we want I want to watch your stupid ass
[ __ ] event
and you're gonna claim me does that make
sense make it make sense
it's still saying no restrictions so
so I can watch it you think okay all
right I'll let you decide on that I
think it's fine yeah so like
is your street you're called The Stream
easy you don't want anyone to stream it
also like technically I was watching the
mainstream
I was watching the pre-show
it started at six I was watching it
since like 5 45.
and then right before the event started
the stream just died and then I had to
watch it on this dude's personal channel
did you guys have the same thing yeah I
did and I I'm why am I on his channel
baffled by that I was on his channel the
whole time when you guys said like the
stream died out I was like no I've just
been watching it on his it was his was
up so simultaneously yeah I guess so it
was like dual
streaming yeah they were streaming it on
which I that I can maybe understand a
little bit that might have been you know
part of his deal to host it is you got
to let me simultaneous it on my Channel
or something but then the official
Streamys YouTube or yeah Streamys I kept
the steamies and stream he's confused I
know I know the official Streamys
YouTube channel uh had a feed and pretty
much right as it started it abruptly cut
off uh so oh a lot of people are saying
they had the same thing it was so weird
God damn
you know we were gonna have before
Frenemies fell apart we were planning
the biggest
steamies ever we were gonna get we were
gonna do this except good
right how [ __ ] awesome would have
that been
so awesome
what could have been a dream and invite
everybody to to build all the losers
they'd have to come it's an honor of the
winners
all right so here's a-rack whoever he is
uh
coming at me let's see uh dream isn't
here but he had a huge year he finally
took off the mask let's go dream
let's hope uh Ethan Klein takes his off
next
huh
oh I'm being told this is actual that's
his actual face I'm so sorry Ethan got
it yeah let's straight up a Jimmy Lee
joke like that is old time music that is
old time music
take off the mask oh what is it trick or
treat Charlie over here
like this dude actually wrote that joke
man that's crazy
[Applause]
yeah I had to go back I was like what I
what the [ __ ] but I mean it's nice to be
it's nice to be mentioned I guess
right
yeah it's an honor but I'm like
ubiquitous ubiquitously known as the
ugly [ __ ] yeah that I'm the guy hey take
off the mask you're scaring the kids
work with me
yeah I think it was like an
acknowledgment roast at the beginning
prob yes nice I like to be acknowledged
yeah yeah a real knee slapper because
they sat you in the back the host may as
well say your name you know true Ethan
Klein takes his off next
oh wait he's not wearing a mask
got it okay oh [ __ ]
um
yeah uh dream isn't here but he had a
huge year he finally took off the mask
let's go dream
let's hope Ethan Klein takes his off
next
huh
oh I'm being told that's exactly that's
exactly I'm so sorry I uh oh the crowd's
going wild that time I have a uh chatter
saying he didn't write the joke it was
given to him Hassan asked him
that's insane because why would you do
but why would you go up why would you
host an event where you don't write the
material and you go up and saying shitty
jokes written by like I mean this is
Tyler Oakley
like Tyler you know Tyler Oakley's
involved in this [ __ ] still some for
some reason
[Laughter]
because he's not a professional comedian
like to get to give him a little bit of
slack here you know he was doing his
best and but he's not a professional
host he's not a professional comedian uh
I'm not surprised that
I'm sure most of it was written for him
if you're gonna hire a writer
um
you don't get a famous host because it's
like well what's the point but you can
get famous writers because nobody sees
them
well not a few of the Streamys I don't
know low small budget yeah they got
Kimmy Lee would have been way better
yeah they should have Jimmy Lee hey who
you gotta can't Hey where's uh who's
another famous like um is Andrew Tate
here where's your camel famous uh
Islamic uh Creator uh yeah Andrew Tate
um
he also took a dig at Hassan do we have
that one yeah he took like the lowest
hanging fruit Jabet Hassan ever
apparently he apologized until it's on
it was so bad I haven't gotten my
apology for the record well you weren't
there
well you can reach out I don't know how
but figure it out bro you can get at me
okay my ass was in the middle you need
to come to me check your DMs
on Instagram
wait there's oh this is it yeah
here's his dig at Hassan yeah
do an award for the most anti-capital
Capital I'm not sure where he is right
now uh probably in his 200 000 car
socialism has never looked so good dude
that joke is like so [ __ ] it's not
it's like yeah we've heard that a
billion times did you did an AI bot
write this joke I mean like they just
pulled from it's like you just Googled
who these people were before the show
like recent controversies he really
didn't write that because who would
write that [ __ ]
someone sent him out there to get
murdered it's just people that worked on
the street seriously yeah
on this whole event because yeah what
the
[ __ ] did they do a dry run he's I
really wouldn't put too much blame on
the guy
he's they tossed his ass to the walls
bruh put them out there in that outfit
which I think is the bigger yo now he
didn't dress himself either dad that's
really not a fan of these outfits Dan
loves this guy he's like okay let's
bring it up I want to talk about this I
was driving okay I got in the car and I
see Dan talking about the outfit
and then I drive for a half hour and I
get to my house and I see seriously no
one's back about the office
was weird and nobody else seemed to be
on the same page yeah it's weird it was
I it's not I mean look it's I don't like
it it's not great but um someone in chat
said what if he apologized to the fake
Ethan that I would accept that right
yeah but like what if he did it we just
don't know well Ian would know he was
with them yeah we received no no sorry
what about fake Ian
I'd have to check with him okay
you know
and I've been trying to make this all
serious now and I've been trying so hard
bro to lose weight and you're gonna go
up there on stage in front of 10 to 20
people and call me
call me ugly how dare you
I want to speak to the writers
if I was him and I wrote that though I'd
be like nah they wrote that [ __ ] for me
um it wasn't me dog
sorry homie it wasn't me
what's so bad is like the the leading up
to it the setup for it saying uh dream
had a huge year and then the crowd
collapsed and he took his mask off uh
Ethan needs to take off his mask like it
was just so much build up for her well
there was some good notes in the
comments here someone said could have
been let's hope Ethan Klein puts one on
next yeah that would have been a lot
cleaner yeah a lot more to the point
much easier to understand good punchline
uh but uh we did see the he follows you
on Instagram which is an interesting yes
development so I was like is this a jab
of Love or a jab of uh
jabby yes a jab of jabber and I went to
him on Instagram and I went to the DMS
and then because I'm not Savvy on all
this DM stuff but you said it said will
you accept a message from him but there
was no there's nothing there so he had
messaged me something and deleted and
deleted so we're like is he a fallen fan
or like a current fan
maybe he sent you an apology and then
realized that it was an imposter that
was there like [ __ ] this guy and unsent
the apology or maybe he sent he found
his Instagram and sent it to him you're
right yeah
he's like oh [ __ ] wrong Ethan it's such
a shame that they didn't um
the production wasn't on the level of
them getting
uh reverse shots of like audience
members because like a hard cut from
that joke to the fake Ethan would have
been so [ __ ] funny yeah
they put a jab at me they're not even
gonna put me in the front row to get a
reaction like if you want to be like
Ricky gervation of the Academy Awards
you got to do that yeah it didn't seem
like they had they were really on the
ball with that they learned irrelevant
people it's hard to do though because
you have to have the cameraman memorize
the seating charts they need to know who
everyone in the room is it's a little
it's a little too advanced for the for
the streamies
steamies would never yeah but ugly by
the way thank you Bella Simmons who we
love so well for 50 gifts you're such a
yo hello an angel well in the chat well
uh
yeah what are we saying maybe
I was just saying that I imagine the
crowd looked like uh the crowd did when
fousey gave his speech right I felt gay
I felt that no like that's based on what
they told me yeah I said how do we know
this is the real Ethan
this one right here yeah we don't well
that one doesn't look anything like me
so
okay that makes sense yeah this this is
that one wasn't good at all so I don't
think you have to be worried
uh so there's that I got roasted by
a-rack
and he's a I don't know anything about
arack he's a comedian vlogger he has 11
million Subs so
he's apparently friends with Logan Paul
got it he makes expensive Vlogs and
Challenge videos like Mr beast wow super
original
a better joke than he [ __ ] did about
you man that wasn't a joke bro he's very
original
you know what I mean
I gave ten thousand dollars to the
[ __ ] poorest loser I could find
versus 100 supermodels I I gave ten
thousand dollars to the most Haggard
looking [ __ ] up homeless piece of [ __ ]
I can find
try not to laugh all right let's see
what the [ __ ] your videos are like these
are six of my best friends who are about
to start a real play in front of a real
audience he only catches is they have no
idea what they're wearing not enough
energy you need to be screaming outside
the gate dude intensity Turn It Up watch
some more Mr Beast videos for some tips
I just got six of my best friends
all right let's go to the best part
which is apparently here story time okay
that's it
there's a little twist that storybook
you see on the chair right there is what
one might call an adult storybook what
what did you put in there I actually
didn't put anything in there but in this
actual children's book that you can
literally buy there are a series of
adult jokes that were strategically
written
I'm not judging because I I'm not
investing the 15 minutes to watch
so I'm not I'm not gonna hate
I'm just gonna say
you could never do what I do
okay
I didn't see that going there I got a
little afraid for a second
anytime you say I'm just gonna say I'm
like oh [ __ ]
I'm just gonna say no no let's just say
let me put it this way
let me just put it this way
see I didn't do anything
hold on uh no no no no no no we probably
won't have that until next year
let me just say this
behavior until then let me just say this
if a rack is vatic is Vatican City
no no no no
okay and you come right there yourself
you can write the joke for yourself stop
you know what I mean
do you have a video playback of uh Ian
Stein at the uh oh I want to see that
I'm excited let's check it out oh how I
actually lost 500 000 for Mr B this is
me 99.7 of the way to winning 500
000.
all of it here's how I got here three
months ago I got a call from the biggest
YouTuber on the platform this is where
you start the video all that was the
purpose before then and here's
everything that happened three months
ago I
for Mr Beast
damn you'd be a good YouTuber Dan you
get it yeah these guys now have so much
you gotta watch you gotta watch the
master at work
yeah so okay whatever so uh let's get to
the uh
let's get to it
um go ahead and roll it Ian we were
there let's see what happened on the
floor go ahead
[Music]
all right so I'm here uh waiting for the
red carpet I don't I don't really know
any who any of these people are I don't
really know anyone here yeah so Ethan
couldn't be here tonight and he sent me
some reasons yeah so like he's got kids
he had the longest day ever he didn't
have a babysitter uh you know just
general laziness and he never leaves the
house it's got social anxiety never
intended to go and a billion other stuff
I don't really know who Ethan is uh my
name is Jake I've only watched one video
of Ethan's uh The Vape Nation one you
know Vape Nation so I you know I'm kind
of like I consider myself an expert I
know some of his best works
foreign
thank you it's me
dude that carpet's so red it's like uh
the bowling alley I usually go to
[Music]
me
right here
foreign
[Applause]
I was really nervous about my Awards so
and potentially you know he was hoping
what's your favorite moment in 2022 when
it comes to all the content that I know
that you've created this year
did uh I did some great uh podcast
content uh some of the guests were
phenomenal
if you could remove one word from your
vocabulary this year what would it be
probably the word [ __ ] it's an ugly word
yeah the word bomb to it right I think
we can all I think some people would
agree with that as well oh my God Ethan
you made it dude that's crazy
you dream like I really thought that you
would not make it to an event like this
we haven't chilled in a while bro I know
we'd host a podcast together left field
so yeah we haven't chilled in a while I
know man how are you doing okay I gotta
go bye Ethan all right man catch you
later
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't have a new vacation
all right see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
this is great this is like my seventh
one
so you guys aren't the real critical huh
nah these guys are in Boss rooms
[Applause]
this is super awkward we gotta stay here
with these guys with these clowns
[Applause]
foreign
ERS for being a part of this incredible
community and I really mean that
oh this food's [ __ ] great how long do
I have to be here I told my neighbor I
was gonna feed his ferret but uh it's
been like three days and I don't know if
he might not be alive anymore this is
cool though
yeah
you guys drive me nuts I hate fake
people and the streaming goes to
tomato
[Applause]
[Music]
dream you finally took off the mask
let's go dream
let's hope Ethan Klein takes his off
next oh I'm being told this is actual
this is actual face I'm so sorry Ethan
got it okay I'm so stoked uh hi Justine
is here damn they're roasted me pretty
hard there they said I wear a mask or
something
it sucks can I bring out more cheesecake
more cheesecake please
cheesecake's against subscribers in an
attempt to fill a boy beat that aside
from him not getting enough attention
is
technology
sorry I got a little lost
he's no Frank Sinatra I'll tell you that
was great
[Applause]
this is absolutely
presented by the Elevate prize
Foundation now I love this dude Jay
Shetty he's the best real streamy
winners
podcast all her daddy I told you guys
hey please welcome Miss Darcy and Ian
Boggs
hey Ethan you lost so hard
controller right now and we have a
waiver GameCube wireless controller
we're just whooping your ass yeah you
sucked harder than a Dyson's vacuum yeah
[Applause]
we lost two it's okay we lost two let's
make more like I'm sick of wearing this
wig yeah
man that was [ __ ] it was all
[ __ ] call her Daddy what even is
that what was any of that great
cheesecake I'm more of a TV guy you know
Netflix well you know who I really love
Philip DeFranco that guy's awesome
anyway I'm over this [ __ ] this I'm gonna
go watch Netflix Real Entertainment
happens
[Music]
as you can see
despite losing we had a really good time
I had a really good time there and uh
thank you Ian actually for spending your
evening at that
[ __ ] event yep
great cheesecake and I didn't even talk
about like the they had like the
entertainment with like the notepad
trying to break the Guinness world
record for most notepads on the face I
mean that was what I was trying to say
when they when the yada yada yada are
award that we were robbed of yes it's
not really our award our category it was
so that they could [ __ ] have a dude
put on 20 t-shirts in 30 seconds and
they didn't even win the award and he
didn't even do it they're like maybe if
he had done it
it's almost like like yo let's make the
shittiest award show possible that's our
goal let's start from there let's do
another segment where dude puts on
shirts real fast
let's do one work we'll put some notes
sticky notes on her face
Epic
I did 200 shirts you [ __ ] look it up
right yeah
right yeah
I'm the shirt guy whoa I didn't even
think of that but how long did it take
you to put them on
long time okay hours [ __ ] yeah
definitely was no uh
no record setting there well anyway that
was it so yeah and anything else to say
in summary Ian other than that it's a
sham that was Rob there's a scam that it
was a setup that their fraud
organization they have no credibility
they're horrible they represent the
worst of influencers they literally make
influencers look bad by just being such
a poorly run organization
um anything else to say about it Ian
um I had a pretty good time I'm wrong
yeah
put on a hell of a show
Ethan I'm a yoga teacher training and
just learned that weird angle that
happens when your arms straight is
called a carrying angle
not an issue it's just genetics also do
it again LOL
sure I'll do it for you
hit us but see it I'm wearing you gotta
roll up the sleeves yeah it's just not
the same
this one's for you a rack
[Laughter]
uh that looks so crazy oh [ __ ]
that's crazy
does anyone like this a-rack guy does
anyone actually know who he is I mean
he's got 11 million sub usually when we
talk about a Creator there's a lot of
fans in chat right uh true I mean
earlier
uh like even Keith I was like [ __ ]
soy face Keith and everyone's like we
both Keith
we worship Keith
who is Keith again he's the tri he's the
soy sauce he was the one that cheated
right no no no no oh one of the other
ones he's the hot sauce soy guy oh he
there are people saying he's into that
gotcha Chief no the interviewer wait oh
Eric oh the girl who interviewed him
yeah but actually turns out the
impersonator is the man so we're
definitely gonna have to send him to
more events on my behalf that was funny
and great job Ian as always you know
thank you thank you to build it build it
people are saying they never heard of
them wait let's do a poll on a rack
and say
do you know who arach is yes or no do
you know who people are saying bodded
Subs yeah that's what I'm feeling
uh I don't know that's a that's a lot of
bots yeah why you could do it
no not all bot I'm just I don't think he
bought I'm just kidding it's like a i r
r a c k or something
hey there it is air rack
j-r-h-n-br yeah right yeah
yeah because
every time we've talked about a big
Creator there's fans in the chat and
this mother this dude has no fans you
have no fans bro well let's find out I
just threw up the pole
you have no fans bro
how is it a bad poll it's it's simple
yes or no do you know who he is it is
confusing to write no it's not do you
know who he is no that we've never seen
a blowout like that yeah that is I'm so
sorry guys I have to go to I'm like
I have to go to the bathroom again
clenching I'm clenching I'll be right
back it'll be I'll be fast I promise I
don't know all right I got something we
can talk about Dan I sent it in Discord
uh this has been popping up on the
subreddit and I am
I'm just in shock I'm in awe what no
this isn't real from years of playing
basketball I'm told this is real no way
ladies and gentlemen I present to you
Lebron James feet
those are the feet of a goat According
to some people not me one of my
grandparents feet look like that low-key
are they good at basketball no they were
variable though
dude what got the brown bunions I don't
even understand we need cement to weigh
in on this I don't think he'd be I don't
think he'd be into it
I don't think he'd be into it at all we
need an expert opinion though that's all
I'm saying
hmm
okay just saying I bet Jordan's feet
look better
I'm just gonna say that
what about feet are you 100 sure this
isn't like manipulated somehow this is
so cursed I think that it's it's like
the anger like his I think it's just his
small toe is going over that toe yeah
get that but then everything else I mean
let's see
yeah it's a small toe throwing me off
too
it's like what is it called uh
yeah feet binding the thing that was
like that old Chinese custom
oh yeah yeah that would like
intentionally deform their feet to like
keep them small and almost I like ballet
yeah she had to tell me look at Shaq's
feet oh my God I don't want to yeesh
well thanks a lot for sharing that yeah
I got you I'm curious to see what z-man
would think of these believe me from
this conversation
oh I see so Jovita meets the world that
was me interviewing I can't believe I
made it on H3 and it was my birthday
scared uh Hassan right before
though trying to get an interview
well
I appreciate you uh doing that you
you were very funny you were obviously
in the know about the whole yeah that
was great I was cracking up thinking
about did you watching that when I got
home did she just uh roll with it or did
you kind of brief her on no what was
going on right out the gate really funny
happy birthday good birthday
hold on
no you got to be kidding me no that one
I can't confirm but stop
all right I guess we gotta show it it
looks like it was taken at your
apartment maybe it looks like your Tick
Tock yeah y'all know Shaq is everywhere
he comes by sometimes looks like this
that actually does look in my apartment
looks like the stem of a pumpkin dude oh
crazy the stem of a pumpkin yes it does
right yeah some Halloween [ __ ] right
there fighting feet wow
well Psy is a he's like almost a size 30
shoe or something like that yeah I know
he had gargantuan feet but I know they
look like that
okay well that's great that was great
that ruined my day here I'll give you
some quotes about LeBron's feet that
these people wrote give me some quotes
uh started from the bottom now we hear
LeBron's pinky toe uh dog pile on the
big toe
this is the literal most toe jam I've
ever seen
there you go
wow those are banners pretty good Banger
alert this is what happens when you
don't wear Jordans that's what happens
we wear LeBrons yeah
Zach got some really nice Jordans a
little jealous I've been waiting a long
time for those jays I'm happy for you
buddy you're wearing them right now no
they're coming at the end of the week me
and Zach already spent our bonus yeah
exactly wait how much did you spend on
these no it wasn't an insane I got I got
a Gucci bag
that's insane
this and it's relative to how much you
spent yeah it's not astronomical but
yeah the Jordan one lost and founded
I've been one of those [ __ ] shoes for
like eight months for eight whole months
yeah and a [ __ ] Nike sneakers app
[ __ ] itself he's been crawling through
the desert without a canteen for eight
months eight [ __ ] thinking about
these shoes it's like a lifelong dream
come true it's an event they're a really
cool shoe it's an investment how much
did you spend on the [ __ ] shoes how
much you like to know but I would that's
why I'm asking
it was like 400. okay that's not as bad
as I thought yeah I mean that's more
than I would ever spend on people MSRP
is like 180 200 out the door but you
know you got to pay a little premium on
the I thought you're gonna say like two
grand or something [ __ ] that no way I
would not spend two grand on show okay
okay and how much was that bag baby I'm
a bad [ __ ] that's all you need to know
it's uh it was it was a lot but I've
been wanting it for a while I had
another Gucci bag that returned because
it was too small so you've been wanting
for a while like a couple weeks like
last two weeks no no no no but I felt
inspired by Zach's story of getting
those shoes he's been wanting for a
while so there you go man we worked hard
okay
and Lena didn't want to go through the
mall so I want to teach her a lesson
you're not going to come with me I'm
gonna treat myself
and come home with a Gucci bag no
comment
I'm sorry I did the first week he's
a perfect bag and it's just
exhausting he had a really he had a
really nice to me bag he showed me I had
killed me back last week I returned that
over there that was a nice bag it was
too small what was the price difference
I'm sure what are you keeping in a bag
my daily carry okay right
huh this is a new addition but what's in
my bag wet ones okay use those on your
ass this is my the best charger ever uh
yeah it charges both of our phones mine
and Lena's to full excellent sunglasses
right they fold yeah I lost it that's a
nice little case yeah very efficient
okay hold on you see nice that special
Keys okay fantastic what's next what's
next
a cord for the phone with a little zip
tie on it damn very nice
lip chat chat chapstick whatever lip
challenge
gluten-free and then uh my wallet all
right very good very cool thank you
would you say this is the perfect bag
you found the perfect bag now
no he'll have another one in a couple
weeks yeah because I came home and Lena
was like it's okay I'm like [ __ ]
come on and is it like a fanny pack like
how do you it is it is a fanny pack that
I wear sideways okay did you have to
wait in line at the Gucci store I
actually have a girl like Gucci uh shout
out to Lena oh he's got to go yeah I
texted him oh he's got a Gucci girl yeah
oh my God shout out Selena I have
Bloomingdale's you got Bloomingdale's
all right that's different that's oh
it's crunchy and Bloomingdale right all
right that's a different vibe it's not
like oh in the Gucci store
I
can justify it better does it cost this
different amount no I mean just I didn't
add Gucci
huh but she's a Bloomingdale's employee
oh also the damn bag I keep my airpods
in there but they don't uh is her name
in your phone
the bag was 1400 Oh my God
that's why Zach gave you a lower value
than what his shoes actually cost
because he knew you were reacted what
the hell what yeah but I didn't
go ahead my car costs less
literally
I got a perfect bag dude Hollywood
changed me you got the perfect bag Teddy
fresh
that's right yeah this is the perfect
bag right here dude sorry sick I just
need to get a first guy like cams and
I'll be good yo where the [ __ ] is Ethan
he's taking a huge dump from the [ __ ]
dump Arena he's [ __ ] juicing out of
his [ __ ] yo
people some people say ooh let me tell
you something ew I've been broke my
whole life not my whole life but at
least for like the past 10 years so now
that I actually have uh making some
decent money I'm treating myself it's
Christmas it's interesting yeah it's
worth it you've gone completely elevated
dude yeah exactly you come out here oh
I'm allergic to gluten now
[ __ ] L.A yeah I did that's fine
that's why I told Lena I'm like when I
go home I can't let my friends know I'm
gluten-free
roast the hell out of you so what about
the Lebanon zatar
so that's why you can afford it all he
eats is yeah right all right I've been
saving up no but I yesterday me and Lena
had Lebanon gluten-free toast it wasn't
bad actually it was so good yeah but no
like I'm fine with only gluten-free
bread from now on yes do they make
gluten-free zatar
sure and I think it's gluten-free
already
because of you guys it slaps I love how
you guys say it love now how do you say
it
not very different but yeah well that
stuff's yummy and I eat it
I'm glad you guys like it thank you one
of us one of us one of us
Dan you too right we know you love
Lebanon oh I do I do I do indeed I can't
say that I've been getting it
independently though but I should start
I don't know why not
just have it whenever you guys bring it
around which has been less lately I've
noticed I'm gonna miss that yeah I know
I I haven't been going to that Bakery
sorry I was distracted all the labs and
you're not obligated too I don't speak
broke I'm sorry yeah please Jesus Christ
please thank you guys all right so here
come the subreddit post bring it oh my
God I live for this [ __ ] I just lost
some more weight y'all I just lost yeah
I bet you did what did I miss uh
yeah I don't know if I'd wanna
but you don't want to go back it's yeah
it's
it's fine I get it you guys just talked
about it for like 10 minutes yeah yeah
whatever it was I'm sure it was good
I kind of we talked about spending money
and I kind of spent some money too oh
what do you spend some money on
it's right here yeah so I was wondering
did you buy that is that real
it's an official one yeah how'd you find
that yes
eBay baby it's B1
this is a rarity bro how the [ __ ] did
love get one before I got mine that's
crazy
do you recognize this Ethan what okay
[ __ ] you've sold me out thank you so
much for your support it means a lot to
us we hope you find great comfort in
this life-size dunny both emotionally
and sexually your friends Ethan and Eli
yeah so
those were originally sold for like a
hundred dollars yeah because we we're
like this who's gonna pay for this crap
but like either was hustling on the side
because she didn't want to wait tables I
didn't want her to either sure so we
were just trying to make it work
um full time
and I was making like a thousand dollars
or maybe two or three I don't remember a
month probably a thousand a month
and that was like our merch it was these
handmade and sewn dolls
and we had like the normal sized ones
which we sold for like 40 bucks and then
the life-sized ones we've sold for a
hundred
it was such a crazy operation uh and I
don't think we sold many of those
life-sized ones for a hundred maybe like
seven I don't know wow there's a there's
no Rarity yeah I saw that was 1500 on
eBay I saw a Reddit post about it yo did
you spend that much on it
yeah
you spent 1500 on that bro
spend multiple multiple thousands of
dollars oh my God
wait how much did you spend on it 2K
whoa dude wow
yeah I put it on the company and I don't
think there's seven I don't think
they're seven I think there's way more
less I think you're right I think there
might be three or four or something yeah
you you own one ela's brother own one or
do you guys still own one uh I I
actually I don't even know I I think I
don't know if it's a full-size one
because I've seen it in uh the big
storage closet at your house we have
like 20 normal sized dunnies that we
never sold one of them I'm supposed to
get yeah yeah one of them's for you one
of them's for anyone who's one day you
guys who wants one no but I want it from
the simp off
oh I owe it to you foreign
wow I'm kind of honored love that that's
a huge dude I'm the that's an honor I
got I got all these there's like a bunch
of OG stickers here like 20 of them wow
uh the letter got screenshots of the OG
emails even like everything and uh there
should be two in circulation because uh
ELO's brother owns one and yeah you guys
should own one I think he has a rare
blue one that's crazy you even have the
uh
how do you call it an art when you track
the history yeah I I did my research
that was prominence prominence yeah yeah
you've done the prominence on the dunny
dolls dude you're the foremost expert
I'll tell you exactly how much 2.5 k i
put it on on my company as a business
expense of course
oh my God okay yeah I could have we
could have hooked you up with something
man holy [ __ ] nah dude I wanted to do
legit and I did a secret
wow and he's coming to me uh to America
if I ever get there well I can
authenticate it for you if you want like
uh [ __ ] you got to get it a matching
Gucci bag and uh some Jordans for this
yeah for sure everyone's like you bought
an expensive bag LLB love button a 2500
[ __ ] Donald like oh we love them you you
bought you bought a corporate made
little
bags
he bought a designer Gucci bag
oh you treat yourself that's a nice
treat yourself thank you and how many
times you gotta sometimes you gotta yeah
how much was the bag uh 1400. it's so
expensive but it's not that [ __ ] is
really nice thank you I'm sure it's I I
would hope so yeah for fourteen hundred
dollars that better be the best [ __ ]
bag you've ever owned and it's you know
it's something I'd wear every day you
know I mean it's not like a pair of
shoes or something and I look at it yeah
I'm gonna take I've never seen the bag
like that that they've made would you be
pissed if I got the same bag I'm just
kidding
bro oh yeah this is nice this is like a
crossbody bag can I open it yeah look
inside yeah this is nice he emptied it
out earlier we did a hole we did a whole
thing yeah I mean listen you're doing
well you know treat yourself why not
yeah I mean in my hometown like there's
a lot of like really spoiled kids and
like all their dads buying like really
nice cars and Gucci and G wagons and
they're still in high school I always
look at those [ __ ] and like man
I kind of want you got some real [ __ ]
but yeah
but you know what um
a lot of people have fake Gucci it's
crazy how much people could roll around
with the fake [ __ ] but this is the real
deal baby your Dipper's open how much
does the fake stuff cost like 20 bucks
it sounds like a great deal I want to
buy some figures yeah it's dog [ __ ] I
don't know there it is here let me see
it on you let's see yeah model that for
us
yeah yeah yeah yeah I want to see
everyone
okay
sure no it's Vibe I like it it's low-key
it's a Vibe it's a nice bag see yourself
ladies dude the ladies all have crazy
expensive purses purses why can't the
men treat themselves
King [ __ ] thank you this is actually the
most expensive thing I've ever bought in
my life good holy crap that's real well
I'm I'm touched I'm honored that that's
really you know dude I'm the H3
archivist I needed it love and also
yours is an investment in the Arts like
clearly the value only goes up as time
goes yeah this will increase my net
worth over time I will never sell it of
course how are you gonna
preserve it
uh do you know those suit bags giant
suit bags for okay pants and uh the the
the Blazer I think I'm gonna buy one of
those and hang it and then hang it up
somewhere that's a good idea I would be
careful hanging though because things
tend to get stretched when you hang
you're better off folding like the rule
with shirts is to fold them
yeah so they don't stretch that's true
in my room because it's been laying on
my couch for the past couple days it's
very creepy it feels like very crazy it
is very creepy
dude we used to get the best
[ __ ] value man back then because like
we didn't value our
time at all I mean we didn't have that
many fans we had like 7 000 subscribers
or something so
Ela must have been making below minimum
wage for that and then like she had to
walk to the post office and send it and
the PO the postage was insane your ship
you're shipping in most cases something
from Israel to the United States in a
massive [ __ ] box yeah what did you
guys even make money off of those no I
don't think so I lost money I don't
think so and then we were putting
stickers in it making handmade cards
right and we still only sold like four
of them
well that was part of the lore you know
this one was actually the Lord okay
I was really I was in the UK okay okay
so that [ __ ] put that [ __ ] on
eBay well I guess he took the dub man
that's did you ever talk to the guy yeah
I've been talking to him pretty
extensively
5K I didn't I didn't even I used my
dad's name for everything just because I
didn't want to tip him off that I was me
I was like trying to buy it for the show
kind of yeah yeah yeah because he would
have increased the price if you knew it
was needed for sure potentially yeah
yeah wow so that's awesome he seems like
a good guy he really tried to assure me
some pictures of all like signed
pictures and everything yeah I mean
everyone who bought that back then was
just 100 purely supporting us so
everyone back then was pretty
kind-hearted who who bought those
yeah yeah
when you come back to America love you
should get a second plane ticket and
then just put that next to you on the
plane oh that's so funny that my friend
said the exact same thing and I gotta do
it wait was it you love who flew next to
one of those crazy oh my God yeah so
kind of a full circle moment
someone said I bought the dunny that was
being sold from eBay for 1400. wow jeez
you guys
hit me up the frick
okay well let's let's let's hope that
that pays off for you love I'm hoping
i'll authenticate it dude oh you know
what I mean whatever you need
uh my goal is to get the other one I'm
just saying so hit me up if you got the
other you want to collect them all like
uh maybe because I I think it's four
there might be more I'm not sure watch
that one be fake like a fake Gucci bag
it's a fake dummy he's got that card's
real that card's real yeah yeah that's
the real deal thank God
authenticate him that'd be an
interesting business though because who
the [ __ ] would fake that
yeah no he had the emails from back like
what is it
2006.7 so and I recognize your email
even the one you used back then
chess said skin the bow blacks plus she
used to make more dummies
oh a one of a kind Danny doll out of
Beau black plushies yeah
dude those bow blacks plushies man
now that's an investment Bobby's been
talking kind of mad [ __ ] on on Twitter
and I'm like bro I will refund those
blushies so fast it'll make your head
spin bro
but I'm not gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna hustle those plushies to early
retirement
we can get paid fat dude
144 those little gold nuggets each one
of those
untapped oil reserves of wealth
maybe but we're fine they're like why
don't I just go buy a plushie now it's
not the same you gotta buy one of my
144.
by the way has anyone bought any of
those plushies since we bought ours oh
let's check yeah because it was at 201
when we bought it
if anyone bought it I'd have to assume
it was one of our fans who's trying to
get in on this oh yeah definitely it's
there's 242 so oh so so yeah I think 40
of you Super Troopers are trying to get
an early like on Dogecoin yeah
this is why I'm watching it's only going
to go up in value
yeah but thanks thanks Bobby you sent me
a really nice email talk and it was just
yeah no it was super nice he said he's
always been a fan and he said he's been
he's so sorry it's been hard on us and
that he apologized for all of his homies
too because I don't know they kind of go
hard but he says they do it just for
cloud and it's not personal so I thought
that was that was really nice to him
so there it is Bobby's a fan and we love
that for him
that was really nice
um
yeah we love Bobby sweetheart
should we talk about
um
should we talk about this Riley Reid
uh we could or wait there was one thing
you guys want me to talk so we talk
about the Balenciaga thing
a lot of people have been asking for
your opinion on it it's like I've been
meaning to get to it and I always just
miss it so but I do want to talk about
it yeah so the Balenciaga thing
um white people are spamming Hot Chip
I'm not doing oh because we're supposed
to do it today yeah that got put Pro got
postponed yeah my ass ain't doing no hot
chip for a minute
if we do it Lena the Hot Chip and I'm
down I am down
I just I think I need to eat a big ass
meal right before we go in
okay yeah sounds good after last time I
really thought you're never doing it
again dude it was so painful I swear to
God that was one I don't think I've ever
been in more pain
100 that was the worst pain I've ever
been I think I think I went through the
same thing you did yeah
golly dude
I can't believe you're willing to do it
again though after that because I think
I know how to prevent because the first
time wasn't like that you know I it was
spicy and it went away and I was fine
so I think if I just eat a big meal
yeah I won't die
Gabe curse
you think the gay curse is still
happening
at that point it was though you know one
week after the fact
so okay so Balenciaga thing let's see
so you guys know Valencia it's a massive
uh designer brand that's like super in I
mean it was burning hot hot hot hot
they just did a huge ad campaign with
Kim Kardashian they had posters up
everywhere
you know that ain't cheap
get your [ __ ] ass up and work also
Kanye was working with them they dropped
his ass for the
anti-semite [ __ ] and then they go in
this whole pedo campaign crazy
oh is this where where's the Balenciaga
uh let me see she was in a blue dress in
it they like how'd they like scour the
internet
and it's all gone like are you serious
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days did she really scrub the [ __ ]
internet
no it's just all the news articles about
it yeah I found it add photos
yeah here like this this was massive it
was all over the place Kim Kardashian
for Balenciaga
this was like right before all this [ __ ]
happened and they were just burning hot
they were on top of the fashion world
like really man
every celebrity was wearing them
I had just uh
let's just say I bought something
Balenciaga and then I returned it
because I was like there's no [ __ ]
way
I can go out in public like this it's
just such a fat L and then people even
in like ela's comments are like when hey
Ela uh so what's your plan for your
Balenciaga are you gonna burn it
like people are not down
I think this company is going to be so
severely damaged by this it's
astonishing I know I don't know that
they'll survive it
I don't it inshallah it's a tough label
to have I mean like I just going some
all over the weekend there's spray paint
on the side of the mall saying
Balenciaga supports child whatever I
don't know if I can say it but yeah
it's wild yeah so here's what happened
um
there was kind of three main things that
happened it kept getting worse and worse
so the first thing
is they did this photo shoot with kids
and I I do think like I want to preface
this by saying that
there was a lot of fashion companies
doing shots with kids I think it was
something that was kind of end quote
unquote like uh where's that kith one
yeah so kith did it
and I thought theirs was really cool
it's for a kids line they're not selling
adult clothing but
kith did like their usual kind of
Photography with kids and like the kids
look so sick dude look how [ __ ] cool
this kid looks it says so so I love this
photo I thought it was so cool
and the kids look so awesome like such
little Ballers look at this
and so I think what Balenciaga was
trying to do was to hit this
hit this note but the the difference is
kit actually is making kids clothing
dude this is so baller these are like
the most baller kids on Earth
so it was kind of a Vibe and so I I
think they saw that and we're like
okay let's have kids do our usual stuff
but the thing Balenciaga is kind of like
sexy and edgy and like goth I don't know
if it's goth but is having like edgy and
very sexual
so the thing with kids is kind of a
poorly
conceived so people got mad because
there's like a goth
maybe I'm doing a show here bro this
[ __ ] just drives me insane I just want
to [ __ ] rip off my mic arm I hate
this Amy's mic just collapsed
here I'll come help you mute
and so um
you could I can see you saying this this
was in poor taste you know but I don't
think by itself is really a big deal
this one
but it keeps getting worse and worse so
it's like okay you know this is this is
a little corny with the Bears kind of an
adult looking mesh top I don't know but
then there's another one
this one was a little weirder because
it's like a BDSM leather it's like a gag
right does the bear have a gag I
couldn't tell because it's got well it's
got a face a smile here and a nose is
that a ball gag I don't know
yeah
I don't think it's a guy I don't think
it's a Joker in the leather bondage gear
now I think people were saying it was a
gag I don't think it was a gag yeah I
think that's just part of the bear's
face
but these pigs they just did not do it
as good as kith and anyway
it's definitely like BDSM bear and it's
like weird right so but
yeah it's a harness a beauty so you know
again on face value I think you
definitely would have a right to be like
this shit's weird like don't do that
but on its face value I don't think it
would really cause the brand any damage
but it keeps getting worse okay
so once they posted these images
internet users started looking more into
balenciaga's ads to try to find
if there was other Easter eggs
and interestingly they were right
there were other [ __ ]
so when they looked back and found
Balenciaga spring campaign
here's the image this was so [ __ ]
weird and disturbing like like I thought
this was
I said that stuff and I was like yeah
that's kind of weird and gross but when
I saw this I was like yo what the [ __ ]
so it features a
printout of the scotus ruling related to
p word child p word
they found this an excerpt of the
opinion and what's super weird about
this opinion
is that it made I and correct me if I'm
wrong but I think as I understand it it
made an exemption
it allowed more space for tasteful nudes
of children it was something about is
tasteful nudes of children considered
pee
and like how like if it's within the
context of like like if it's like a
paper where does art end and the child p
word okay begin it's about like that
right now why the [ __ ] yeah
would you put that there it's right and
so that's what this is somehow
somehow they figure that out man and I
mean dude so that's that was super
disturbing
right well right ninja maybe don't die
on this shut up ninja don't die on this
hill
yeah you just really defending Valencia
Balenciaga you would keep going on
how dare you
it's unsurprising that a Nazi would
defend Balenciaga
just like dude what it's crazy because
you think of all these like
pizzagate psychos they're like oh a p
word uh uh conspiracies and [ __ ] but
then they go and do this in the face of
all that I mean it's like
whoa
so also with peace and love the fashion
industry is a lot more uh believable to
be uh involved in this sort of thing
than some random uh pizza parlor a
suburb of Washington that's true there
is a lot of scandals with designers and
underage yeah that industry is yeah
but this is marketing and this is like
some Ad Agency so this is another this
is one part already that's [ __ ] up and
weird and gross but there's actually
even a third part
that have surfaced
check this out
so apparently this guy here's someone
modeling this is also from last year
and in the back there's a book from a
guy named Michael Borman
Borman is a Belgian artist whose fire
from the Sun Painting shows a group of
toddlers some of them blood staining
their skin and some of the images they
toddlers appear castrated
right like the guy is I guess known for
really disgusting child freaking p word
art it's [ __ ] horrific did you I
didn't look at any of the art no every
article I read about it they were like
look at your own
like I'm warning you don't even look it
up
really yeah the or the main article was
like do it if you want to but so why the
[ __ ] would this book be there this is
like an obscure artist
it's so [ __ ] gross who what is going
on here dude
yeah and like uh every item has to be
itemized too for a shoot like this like
everything has to be oh yeah it's
definitely all very important no
question about it I'm I don't [ __ ]
know so the question becomes like
obviously Balenciaga apologized I don't
think the bigwigs of the company had any
idea I mean that would be insane why are
you running a business and putting that
in there it doesn't make sense but
clearly somebody there
either in the marketing team or the Ad
Agency
did this intentionally yeah I can't
imagine the money people who own it you
know what I mean like well I mean they
certainly would have signed off on like
that photo shoot and stuff
but yeah they probably didn't listen to
this idiots
if you will
Robin Mason balenciaga's Global PR
director says there's no connection
whatsoever between Balenciaga and Borman
none of the suggestions are factual why
is it there why the [ __ ] is it there and
where every detail is crafted
dude denying this is not good enough I
feel like I need an explanation like I
actually I need to know why this
happened
somebody needs to explain what the [ __ ]
who did this there's got to be someone
who put that book there who put that
scotus ruling on the desk
it'd have to be the uh
like whoever the creative director art
director creative director since he was
yeah I need to know like this this needs
an explanation it's not good enough
to just be like oh man that's crazy
let's not buy Balenciaga anymore I I
need to know like who did this
so you guys think it's just one
one who's like slipping it in I don't
know maybe I have no idea I have one
individual group of individuals but I
mean certainly somebody that was on the
set that you know was involved directly
with the creative of like laying out
uh what these shoots were gonna be and
yeah I mean I agree like even if it was
there
and if the higher upset the agency we're
reviewing this to send it out or
whatever they would not probably
wouldn't have picked up on all the weird
little Easter eggs so yeah I I'd assume
it was people directly involved in the
shoot
yes so Kim Kardashian was in the midst
of this huge campaign with them so they
had to scrub all that [ __ ]
they re-shot stuff with other models
they had to like scrub cam out of all of
it I'm sure by her demanding
and um here they addressing the
situation
but like the the potential motives for
doing something like this is like either
it's like corporate espionage
oh like sabotage I mean they're trying
to get them in trouble yeah yeah I mean
Kanye said that that's his theory when
Alex Jones asked him about it it's not
it's like kind of the most plausible
thing if the other alternative is like
there's a there's like a child predator
who's winking to his homies like that
like why would you risk that I don't
have a very uh charitable opinion of uh
that whole industry personally so I I
lean more towards something like that
than some sort of sabotage thing but
like that you just have nothing to gain
it's it's not really plausible
explanation at least as far as I can
understand because there's nothing to
gain these people are doing stuff that
is so [ __ ] illegal and so universally
loathed like why would you
stick your neck out like that just to
say what up to your home is and I'm just
spitballing here I don't know but I'm
just saying like it's like it's just
weird
but it could be it could be I don't know
I don't know
it's just weird yeah
it's so weird it's beyond weird it's
it's so here's Balenciaga they posted a
story not even a [ __ ] post
someone wanted to cause a stir to me
that makes the most sense because like
there's a there's a cause and effect
someone did this with the attention and
then they could leak it they could post
it it'd be easy for them to point it out
yeah but I mean this oh the child p word
one was on their big Adidas collab too I
forgot they did a huge collab with
Adidas and that one was on the desk of
the Adidas club and so Adidas lost their
[ __ ] and had to [ __ ] scrub all that
too so this happened in basically the
worst time possible for them were they
with Kim Kardashian and Adidas on one
side right before right before like the
biggest sales time of the whole year
this couldn't have [ __ ] them any
harder any harder can't drop me
uh it's weird man you know what I mean
it's just so weird
if it was sabotage though they'll find
out I'm sure they're they're I'm sure
they're trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] happened to them
what would somebody stand again for
sabotage though that's that's my
question okay but so let me let me talk
about that but I see one comment because
this is kind of the conspiracy theory
stuff they say to slowly integrate this
weird mentality into mainstream
I don't believe that that's I don't
believe that that's what it is you could
you don't just like casually put like a
scotus ruling Easter egg that's not
doesn't fed people's subconscious you
know what I mean
I don't think
right you can maybe make that argument
for the the photo shoots with the kids
or whatever yeah yeah yeah Easter egg
things like it yeah it nobody unless
they're heavily scrutinizing it which in
this case they did would even notice
that so it's not
it's not like programming people uh
nobody would even have realized it was
there
I just got a donation from from morgue
pie thank you morgy
hey Ethan I just had my first shoot with
browsers two days and I got gonorrhea
uh
on PornHub and she always she always
like showing support to me Elena so
shout out and I'm sure oh she does yeah
that's nice shout out get well soon yeah
I'm sorry about the gonorrhea
and congratulations on the job yeah bill
by the way I'm surprised I thought they
were more I thought they were like super
careful yeah that was my thought too
especially
like the more official uh porn companies
like that that's [ __ ] up
damn browsers hit you with that
gonorrhea girl
what are they doing about that I'm
curious do they so do you call them and
be like yo I got that
I got gonorrhea what are you gonna do
about it like do they do they you know
what I mean do they do they do something
for that they send you to their browser
stuff ability right aren't they
obligated to test yeah the performers
yeah is that it
yeah if you want to call in
I'm actually curious about the whole
browsers thing
so there you go yeah DM me anywhere and
that's why you should be virgin
the only way to prevent gonorrhea is
abstinence abstinence that's right acid
this is an abstinence podcast
anyway thank you morgue pie who has
gonorrhea
you know they treat gonorrhea it's kind
of crazy uh I I may have had it once in
college really I had some discharge but
I never tested positive were you in
Brazzers I don't even I gotta remind
myself of what it's just like a little
and it's just like an infection in the
dick pole and it there was like I know
this is super gross but it just made me
think of it
and the treatment for it's really crazy
you just eat some like uh like
powder for allergies it's like not even
a medicine meant for gonorrhea and you
pee it out and it just kills all the
bacteria it's a single dose of 500
milligrams of intramuscular
reaction some powder I just mixed in
water and drank right there in the doc's
office and boom
but they tested it and it didn't come
back positive which was weird but I
thought for that Adam he's so bad it's
the only time I ever had
that was [ __ ] yeah it was gross not
good
so I'm right there with you morgpai
I don't know if it was gonorrhea or
chlamydia what's the difference
it wasn't syphilis I know that what
chlamydia uh I don't know specifically
but
I think chlamydia is also a relatively
uh
treatable one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
those are not to say that it's not a big
deal it is but like it it can be
addressed fairly easily someone said
maybe it's a yeast fiction I maybe I
don't know like I said I never tested
positive but
didn't look right I'll say that
fine now by the way she said she'd call
in
okay I I'm actually curious about the
whole browser thing
I want to know what they're doing for
her you know what I mean
um I guess
who's in contact with you
um
here I'll send you a zoom link I guess
Ethan that was definitely not gonorrhea
both it and chlamydia are treated with
antibiotics
I swear dude the doctor was like yo just
drink this [ __ ] and you're good and I
did and I was good
I went to Planned Parenthood too they're
like just drink this [ __ ] huh
I'm trying to think what else it could
have been
that you might be misremembering well it
could have been a yeast infection sure
that's possible
uh so anyway uh I guess we're not done
with the Balenciaga thing so let me
finish this first we sincerely apologize
for any offense our holiday campaign may
have caused our plush bear bags should
not have been featured with children in
this campaign
we have immediately removed the campaign
from all platforms it's like what that
yeah the kids then when you go back and
look at it through this lens then it's
really [ __ ] up right yeah super
disturbing so just uh so the product
being sold in that wasn't the close it
was specifically the bags oh so
apparently the teddy bear is actually a
bag and it opens it has a zipper because
elos was explaining to me that it's
actually like a cool bag okay and that
was like the primary thing that was
being sold yeah yes yes see if it was
just that even though it's obviously in
poor taste you could it's like okay it's
a teddy bear product
you could see like the thought process
they were like oh let's like have kids
with like these teddy bears even if like
the teddy bears are kind of edgy but
then you throw them out
call you what Easton Chieftain dick
cheese oh God those are disgusting shame
on you oh uh she is in the lobby of the
zoom so should I uh
um I guess we could if there's anything
let me just finish this uh if you don't
mind uh Mork pie
he said we apologize for displaying
unsettling documents in our campaign
we take this matter very seriously our
taking legal action against the party's
responsible creating the set and
including unapproved items for our
spring
campaign should we strongly condemn
abuse of children in any form
so that's all they said on it because
they didn't even address the book or
right
oh wait no they did address the book I
read something about how we have no
affiliation with that artist
well other than that there's stuff well
we know that's Affiliated I know I mean
no you didn't we know they don't work
for you it's like duh dude so
um
goofy so yeah Kim Kim uh let's see
uh we strong remove the ads
they named the company North six who did
the design production apparently they've
dropped their lawsuit now uh they were
suing them for like 25 million which
they're gonna lose way more money than
that
the inclusion of these unimproved
doctors result of Reckless negligence
for which Balenciaga has filed a
complaint
was also in the news recently after a
cut ties with the a
I mean yay would have benefited from
putting that [ __ ] there a Kanye fan
just to throw mud in their face for
dropping yay
I suppose that's true it's just it's
just a theory
I mean that happened not that long ago
though and you have to imagine this
campaign was probably planned for
the photo shoot nah no you don't think
so I don't think it happened that long
ago okay probably happened right before
um so why did they drop the suit I see
that uh I don't know why that the suit
two days ago
yeah I find that weird
yeah so here's a guy who's summarizing
the the court thing says read the
Supreme Court dock it's basically saying
that c p is illegal but producing and
distributing sexually graphic images of
C is okay as long as it's not obscene so
Valencia is basically acknowledging the
graphic images but that it's okay for
Supreme Court it's like a loophole for
CP it's [ __ ] Disturbed [ __ ] dude [ __ ]
so [ __ ] weird and gross
and then of course the the right is
going crazy and somehow when the
conservatives they go this is the left
this is the world the left wants
everybody's mad about it of course
this European High fashion house this is
what
like the left wants
like in America like what what are we
even talking about well here's Tucker's
um take on it this is such a like Niche
thing
but it makes sense in their narrative
they say that LGBT they all love Kanye
this dude was working with them until
like a week ago right well they all love
Kanye too a week ago
that's what I'm saying it's just like
what does it happen okay I have no
interest in covering the sexualization
of children Warren Jeff didn't marry
underage girls he's in prison for
facilities
the rapist in this case has made a
lifelong commitment to live and take
care of the person why would anyone
defending Behavior many are defending it
make no mistake they're absolutely
defending it I'm just telling you I've
been raising a marriage between a 16
year old and a 27 year old is not the
same I'm telling a stranger off the
street right here that's [ __ ]
protecting children from adults who want
to sexually exploit them is a basic
human instinct and it's a noble Instinct
and these little girls start
experimenting around next thing you know
what's going on in the comb dormitory
nothing I don't got a PSP to play I
ain't got nothing going on I ain't got
my Mom and Dad here to tell me that they
love me and the in Tech man tucked me in
bed so here's Trixie she wants to
explore my body a little bit so you know
what I don't need to listen I know
Tucker's a creep
yeah so they're suing the production
company for 25 mil
they dropped it I don't know why and so
I just really want to know how who did
this I gotta know why did this happen
yeah I'm quickly speed reading this
article about the drop lawsuit it
doesn't really give a reason there's
like a weird little side note Balenciaga
has said it suspects the background
documents came from the filming of a TV
drama [ __ ] shut up
dude they were laid out so carefully
yeah no [ __ ] stop it see statements like
that makes me more suspect of them just
kind of obviously lying stop it because
you you have like this almost perfect p
word conspiracy theory that people
fantasize is happening all over the
place all the time and so here we have
it and we've caught it and we've got it
so let's figure it the [ __ ] out yeah
I need answers now
all right let's talk to Mork pie okay
all right uh yeah let me um can you
watch Howie's latest Tick Tock it's so
weird uh oh does it have a prolapse
because it's probably not wearing that
hmm
I took it down okay
how long have we been going by the way
we have been going for three hours
almost on the dot okay so here let's
talk to her and then maybe yeah yeah
I'm letting her in right now one second
I get this all set up
[Music]
oh Rory I let I'd make a mole Fork joke
but this stuff just makes me
legitimately sad uh Rory even the mole
people are upset by this I'm with you
all right uh uh morgy are you there
yep I'm here hello
hey what's up you guys
I want I have so many questions for you
awesome I'm a super big fan I love all
of you guys I'm so sorry for derailing
the entire show with my message but I'd
be happy to answer any questions you
have oh we love it this is why I love
doing the show live so I can talk about
stuff like this
so you are
it seems like you are [ __ ] it I Know Who
You Are
oh I can't even pretend
I can't sit here and just pretend like I
don't know I can't keep the act up
anymore
wait for real wow come on
I mean you're one of the most popular
people on p hub right
I guess but I I just like I don't know I
don't think my videos get that many
views that like anyone actually knows
who I am I don't know embarrassing
that's fine dude that is so awesome yeah
I'm glad you guys enjoy my content if
there's anyone else there that does I
really appreciate AB was quick bro he
was like fast like I know her yeah when
yeah when she added me on Twitter I was
I I recognize the name yeah
Beyond flattered thank you so much
it's embarrassing but uh there it is so
I know you're like a big independent
um uh performer you have your own
business so I was curious why would you
go and work for browsers if you were
already so successful independently
because I thought that was the dream
right and then to go work for a big
company seems like
I'm just curious like what what's the
yeah
well uh in March it'll be four years
that I've been directing producing
editing like chilling out all my own
content
um and after a while it gets to be a bit
much uh plus I have much higher goals
for myself
um and I figured working with a big
company like Brazzers might get me into
like Mia malkova's League maybe
something like that you know I feel like
I'm still an aunt on the internet and I
would like to be much bigger
so you think that the browsers will get
you higher profile
I think so yeah so are they able to even
pay you a competitively with what you
make on on yourself or are you just
doing it for the exposure I'm yeah I'm
mostly doing it for the exposure the uh
pay was not much
wow
but wouldn't it be easy for them to get
you then it's like it's just CR I'm
surprised women still do the browser
scene because it just seems like you can
make
so much more money doing it yourself and
have control but you know I guess if if
you want to make it big maybe you still
got to go go with the with the browsers
that's what I'm hoping for we'll see
well if you're if you're a fan of the
show I'm sure that uh there's a lot of
people who will be Googling what is a
morgue pie what is a morgue pie oh god
um it's the worst nickname I possibly
could have come up with but when I was
first starting I was like oh my name is
Morgan and I do you know uh the pies so
just we'll just squeeze those together
yeah there you go
oh yeah and so it's not great but I've
found that it sticks in people's heads
because it's so ridiculous
yeah it is catchy
and so so you went to the shoot so how
was it like compared to working this is
your first time on like a professional
set like that so what was it like yeah
it was my first professional set ever
um it's
everyone on the shoot was very nice they
all said that I killed it everyone was
sweet uh the makeup artist did not do my
makeup to my liking so I was a little
bummed about that but other than that
everything was great and then uh the
next day I wake up and I check my phone
and my shooting partner tells me he
tested positive for gonorrhea and I
should get checked and in that moment
see I I'm in Texas I grew up in Texas so
I I have a Texas sexual education so
immediately I saw that and I fell to my
knees because I was like my life is over
I'm gonna have this for the rest of my
life oh I I was just so distracted you
can catch that [ __ ] every weekend you're
fine no yeah I'm good I I got a I got a
shot in my butt this morning at CVS and
I'm good wait wait wait what'd you put
in your butt
a shot they they gave me a shot oh okay
oh it says you went to CVS they just
gave you a shot in your ass and it gets
rid of it yep that's it modern medicine
so did you were you like yo what the
[ __ ] bro did you hit up browsers like
what's up
yeah so he messaged me and then someone
from Brazzers uh texted me like
immediately after him and they were like
we're so sorry for the inconvenience
like here's a doctor that we use if you
want to go see them and uh yeah that's
basically it I mean I like I had to pay
for the shot and everything myself
oh they didn't even cover it how much
was the shot you're gonna tell them well
I don't have insurance so it was like
200 bucks I mean it's not the worst why
don't you have insurance you're killing
it take care of yourself because it's a
[ __ ] scam and I'm not gonna pay into
it it's not a scam if you if you get
like God forbid you get hit by a car
you're gonna go bankrupt you're probably
so you probably have so much money right
now and you're doing so good trust me
get the [ __ ] insurance otherwise if
something bad happens you're gonna lose
everything you've built
um trust me dude please get the
insurance
do you have any recommendations well I
don't know what it's like in Texas if
you you live in Texas yeah yeah I don't
know yeah I'm in Texas yeah just get
whatever somebody help me out
just get whatever people like there I
don't know because do you have Kaiser
Permanente there is that a California
thing
it might be a California thing I think I
think it's California yeah yeah prior
yeah but get anything please dude trust
me it's like the fir come on you take
care of yourself yeah fair enough
out there you're getting gonorrhea
chlamydia we needed we need to know I I
don't know how far this stuff can go did
you get yourself yeah now it might be a
little more worth it so was the dude
kind of gnarly or was he did he his dick
would probably look fine yeah no he was
great yeah oh and uh I'm so sorry if you
see this my shooting partner I'm so
sorry for outing you
yeah it's fine I mean what's his name
she want to say his name where'd you
live I mean if whenever it comes out on
browsers everyone will know who it is so
his name or you don't have to say but
like you said everyone's gonna figure it
out
oh no I'd rather not stay right now oh
yeah yeah it's fine it's fine
so what kind of scene was it just a
vanilla kind of
straightforward one oh yeah it was just
me and one other guy it was pretty
vanilla and so correct me if I'm wrong
but so God I hate to this embarrassing
to admit no go ahead level of [ __ ]
as far as I'm aware anything you've only
been performing with your boyfriend
right
so
broke up with them a few months ago so
now I have a new regular shooting
partner but up until the Brazen shoot I
had only worked with my ex-fiancee and
my current shooting partner
so this was your first time with someone
else professional like that
yep huh so that's kind of a bad first
start to that party partner the first
time what was that was it weird to have
like being intimate with a new dude like
that in front of all these people I
don't think you probably don't no no not
at all to me I'm very much uh
flip switches in my in my head and I'm
just like oh I'm acting like this is all
for a movie you know there it is
well we're glad that you are cured of
your uh uh gonorrhea or chlamydia or
whatever it is you had
yes yeah and uh well we wish you uh we
wish you well
I appreciate it I love you guys so much
what's your goal you say you have big
Ambitions in the industry what like what
what's the top for you what's the dream
oh man uh if I was like number one on
PornHub like in the out of all everyone
on there like Atlanta Rhodes current
spot wow that's where I want to be
that's ambition right there I see it
she's ready she's out there
how far do you have to go like what
number are you
that's a good question out of out of the
amateurs I'm number five but I don't
know out of everyone on the site I think
that's really good five you're up there
come on more goodbye
ladies and gentlemen
all right thank you morgue pie thank you
so much thanks for coming in yeah thanks
for having me and uh if you get any
other STDs let us know okay
are you doing another browser shoot do
you have it planned or are you taking a
back seat now
they haven't reached out to me for
another scene yet so we'll see hmm yeah
[ __ ] them there's bro I just they just
ended up gonorrhea they're not paying
you well yeah I was gonna say I would be
maybe a little reluctant yeah dude wound
up like that but because wouldn't I mean
I would think that less known actresses
would go on browsers to get a leg up but
I find it interesting that someone who's
well known would do browsers for a leg
up I never thought of it like that I'm
not that well known
do you work on that well to me I know
everything about you no I'm just I'm not
I don't know that
were you you were born in Houston right
I'm just kidding I didn't know that I
just made that
you weren't born in Houston right please
don't yeah okay let's just pretend this
game let's stop this game it's getting
embarrassing okay all right listen
all right thank you Mork pie Take Care
thank you
I'm in your walls more bye
yeah there it is morgue pie fan of the
show
she had gonorrhea she has no more
shout out so did you know who she was
the whole time yeah I did so
embarrassing I didn't I just I didn't
want to admit it that was so [ __ ] I
definitely know who she is said she's
number 31. oh 30 we're all so not that
far oh like of all of uh because I
assume so amateurs she said she was like
five on Amazon yeah right she was a lot
higher um just based on what they told
me
wait why she she lost clout
why'd she go it goes up and down I'm
told you oh you track that see I don't
track the charts I don't track the
charts oh a Casey Kasem you guys got
your fingers on the pool coming up at
number five we have more fun
all right all right
all
right
it's embarrassing I don't like to admit
to any of that stuff
she follows me on Instagram oh so she
probably follows all of us
there you go these are pretty wild for
Instagram I can say
oh really they don't allow like nudity
on Instagram let me check just because I
want to see
just because I want to see how crazy is
it for Instagram it's a little a little
edgy for Instagram but yes dude I
noticed sometimes on on
Instagram [ __ ] gets weird and wild bro
oh yeah this is like straight up like
titties
she's definitely um
a
Trailblazer in terms of how much you can
show on on
Instagram
does this impressive ratio of covering
up to not for Instagram
all right thank you let's not do that
anymore
embarrassed enough for a day
all right we have been going for Nobody
Does it Like Us folks we're here on
Monday we've been going for what three
and a half hours uh 3 15. we'll do it
live [ __ ] it
yeah nobody does do it live you know and
we don't even get any respect not best
show not bad podcast it was even yada
yada there's no [ __ ] respect that
those dreamies they could stream these
nuts bro let's [ __ ] go baby thank you
yeah and stream these nuts right love
[ __ ] yeah dude
Dumbass Dumbass organization
[ __ ] right you're [ __ ] right on with
that and now it's terrible awful no
we're doing the streamies this year
Philip DeFranco ghost to me we're not
we're doing the steamy steamies Philip
Franco's a fake friend he ghosted you I
said do the streamies do the steamies
with me I said well and he's like I
don't want to do it live and I said
we'll pre-record it for you and he
[ __ ] ghosted me well he's a busy guy
maybe just follow up I'm sure he's got a
lot going on also he's out he's waiting
he's waiting for you on the Mountainside
there you go I was about to say Olivia
you want a lot of [ __ ] nerves you
know it'd be Savage a lot of nerves if
he sent an impersonator
that's what that's what you gotta do
okay
I'll send my impersonator then too we'll
have a great shows
all right checking our wives
say what I said I say let's end it in uh
check in with our wives
Ela doesn't care about that okay Elena
doesn't care she doesn't care
she know she knows what it is thank God
nice little switch there again she's on
a phone call outside
you know it's like
when you've been married this long you
just it is what it is and somebody said
check her story she got the trading
cards that's a true fan right there are
you serious oh morgie yeah she's always
rocking Petty fresh
I always felt like that let's go oh
nice oh let me see let's go oh she wears
Teddy fresh yeah all the time oh that's
safe this is like the like real hardcore
family thank you morgify shout out
family that's a perfect type of family
in her world or [ __ ] sorry I just I did
like family and stuff I don't know
I don't know
all right let's wrap it up adult
interest but we have kind of a um
exactly what I mean we have an unusual
schedule this week so we should um
fill in the viewers what's going on not
that unusual what's our schedule I don't
know I I don't know from day I just
distracted what you doing over there
seem a little I'm reposting when my
friend Neil bent over this happened
gotta prove what I'm doing
what about our schedule this week so uh
instead of a usual Wednesday live show
uh we're pre-recording Wednesday's
episode tomorrow and it is going to be
am I allowed to say or is it supposed to
be a total surprise it's fine say it
we're doing Silent Library part two the
triumphant return and favorite Tyler
Library Ian and Sam have been cooking up
some horrible things for us for like
weeks now I feel like you guys if I see
chip working on this
I think it's going to be a little more
creative than the spicy chip but I don't
know that might be involved but we're
recording that tomorrow and so actually
you need to figure out when you're if
you want to do a live see you next
Tuesday tomorrow we gotta we can do it
like we did last week where I'll come
down we'll shoot at two right I'll do my
normal see you next Tuesday at 12. okay
and then come straight to the studio
afterwards all right so we'll do that
yeah and then uh I mean that's the only
strange programming note um Thursday
will be leftovers as normal and then
Friday uh Brittany Broski uh will be
here oh yes that is exciting the return
of another fan favorites I I I I'm so
excited I love Brittany and uh it's just
such a joy to have her back in the
studio
and so basically the only difference is
Wednesday we're going to be uploading
instead of being alive right exactly it
is Wednesday man
all right guys I'm gonna go I'ma go
thanks for being here happy Monday let's
get it it's almost holidays do you know
what I mean just just stay focused get
through it we're almost there guys it's
almost Christmas time it's almost
holiday break yes
you know what I mean just hold strong
baby hold the line
[ __ ] streamies
and a-rack whatever he is 90 93 don't
know who he is who are you dude you're
gonna look at your phone after this and
you're gonna see an apology from him and
you're gonna feel real bad yeah and then
we'll be like he's my best friend I love
him I always did I always have always
will always been a huge fan let me see
if he damned me on Instagram
a rack
let's see if he messaged me
no nothing not even a single apology
well it's coming I'm sure should I
imagine be like dude when's my apology
that's such a dish
whatever
congrats arac for hosting the worst show
of all time
you could never do what I do
you know what I mean poor
anyway oh should we do the poll which
thumbnail they prefer since we're just
kind of lazing about at the end here
we're good numbers I think it's I think
we're good yeah I think people yeah it
was a good one
what about or are you saying the
thumbnail we did I mean we got 43k live
I mean we're doing good okay all right
fair enough all right guys see on uh see
on see on Wednesday I mean I won't be
you know Roc tomorrow for members live
yeah all members thank you thank you
peace and love see you tomorrow at 12.
and the Silent Library on Wednesday okay
thank you thank you this is a serious
message with peace and love
this is a warning
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]